the truckers in Canada have all but one
base they've won and I'll tell you why
they haven't necessarily gotten
everything they've wanted but the
government seems to be cracking Trudeau
seems to be breaking there's reports now
that many of the Vex passports the Vex
magnets are going to be lifted the
government has talked about removing
many of these minutes not because of the
truckers by the way
but they've won for one very simple
reason it is now confirmed from City
officials tow truck companies have
refused to intervene to move any of
these big rigs they have outright said
we work with these guys we're not going
to intervene and the government
responded by these tow truck companies
won't be an obstacle to Us ending this
protest which means what they're going
to seize the tow trucks and force them
to do it it ain't gonna happen not only
that some of these Heavy Duty Towing
Companies said listen unless the
truckers agree to be moved you're it's
impossible to move these trucks the city
is shut down until the truckers decide
so that means as far as I'm concerned
they they control the city and there's
about an estimate of 500 or so trucks
gridlocking the city and there's tens of
thousands of more truckers who are
actively protesting and many other
places the government has one choice
comply with the protesters and the
protesters aren't asking for anything
material they're not asking for money
they're not asking for buildings they're
simply saying revert your decrees the
truckers aren't saying we want they're
saying stop doing the bad stuff you've
done by decree that's honorable
we had a bunch of other news as well
though there's a republican Congressman
who's claimed the Capitol Police special
investigators dressed like construction
workers broke into his office
photographed protected materials and
interrogated a staffer
these are dark days the same day we're
hearing this Louis gomert said that the
doj is spying on mail from his
constituents to him
it's getting crazy out there and then on
a more funny note I guess Donald Trump
has weighed into the Joe Rogan
controversy offering Joe some good
advice saying stand strong don't be weak
and don't apologize meanwhile Neil Young
has doubled down he said it wasn't about
censorship he said it was it was about
you know he doesn't want to associate
with Spotify except even after he's won
apparently and got his music removed
he's calling on Spotify employees to
quit their jobs because it is about
censorship so we'll talk about all of
those things joining us today is Will
Chamberlain
yeah a senior council with the internet
accountability project and the article 3
project
um just fighting you know big Tech
censorship and things like that but
really the last six weeks have been I've
been in the newborn Haze my my lovely
little Elizabeth was born on December
30th congratulations that's very awesome
um Jordan is at home taking care of her
and hopefully watching
um and I'm happy to be here happy to be
back in back in you know joining the the
world of the living so your your
credentials is dead yes yeah that's
right my credentials is Will
Chamberlain's joining the show he is uh
dad and thanks for joining it's gonna be
fun we got uh Sheamus Sheamus Coughlin I
run a YouTube channel called Freedom
Tunes we upload political cartoons every
single Thursday sometimes uh on Tuesday
as well and we uploaded one today as a
matter of fact Tim voiced fouching it
was about the Joe Rogan controversy if
you all want to check that out I'm
excited to be back uh and excited to
have will on we've done a couple shows
before usually really interesting so and
your title is Father father Sheamus no
absolutely first of all that is Stolen
Valor absolutely
I'm Ian Crossland what's up everybody
I'm not a dad yet but hopefully one day
that's my plan and um so I'm excited to
have a baby one of these days and and
will thanks for thanks for doing it and
then
yeah yeah I'm really planning on having
a baby pretty soon so I'm really excited
about it oh excellent yeah excellent uh
you guys follow me incrosson.net but
let's get this show going yes I'm very
excited to be here as well thank you all
for tuning in this evening always good
to have Will's legal counsel or not
legal counsel I'm told and I'm excited
to talk we'll keep going before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member because
we are primarily supported through
memberships on the website that's how we
fund everything and in the event we ever
face any kind of real censorship that's
where we're going to have everything so
your membership is a protective barrier
from the censorship and you know the
activist attacks and all that stuff so
it's really appreciated but as a member
you'll get access to exclusive members
only segments from this show we will
have one for you tonight around 11 or so
p.m that will be at timcast.com so sign
up there support our journalists but
don't forget like this video right now
smash honk that like button one like is
one right
honk give it a hand uh a good hunk and
uh share the video sharing really really
helps subscribe let's jump into that
first story this is incredible so we've
heard rumors there was local reporting
from independent Outlets that they
called tow companies and the company's
like look we're not getting involved in
this we don't want to you know tow these
trucks because we work with them and
things like that but now we have the CBC
and the government acknowledging towing
companies on City contracts even are
refusing to move Convoy Vehicles you're
gonna love this look at this according
to uh canelicos mayor Jim Watson has
reached out to his counterparts and
other Ontario municipalities but no dice
no one wants to help right now the
consensus seems to be that many of them
or most of them don't want to do the
work because they rely on the heavy
truck industry for their livelihood and
they don't want to damage that part of
their business that's the position
they're taking at least Deputy police
chief Steve Bell agreed that finding
companies that will agree to tow
protesters has been a challenge in quote
every jurisdiction that's faced this and
it's forcing us to come up with some
Creative Solutions he wouldn't elaborate
on what those Creative Solutions might
be but said police are coming quote
toward a position where we're not going
to let the tow truck operators be an
obstacle to ending what's occurring I
just want you to think about that last
quote for one quick second
what does that mean they're an obstacle
oh you've gone to a private company and
said I require your service and they
said good day sir and you said you are
now an obstacle to me ending a protest
what are they gonna do steal the tow
trucks and operate them themselves
they're not going to know how to do it
could you imagine some cop being like
let me just figure this thing out I
think I think I can get it they'd have
to steal the vehicles commandeer these
companies because the companies won't do
it it's very difficult to tow trucks
when the tow trucks won't tow trucks
exactly well there's also a quote from
uh local trucker who laughed at the
prospect when they someone asked him are
you worried about getting towed and he
said anybody who's worked with these big
rigs know knows that when you activate
the air brakes these things cannot move
unless the operator wants them to move
so the tow truck drivers are like that's
one of the other stories we have they're
basically saying removing trucks well
they're literally saying would be almost
impossible it's a gridlock think about
it this way too you've got you know
let's say you have four by four trucks
in the road how are you going to be able
to tow one of the trucks one at a time
and try and clear it out it's it's
insane they're heavy duty the companies
won't do it and even if they could these
trucks have basically gridlocked the
area there's smaller cars it's I'll say
this physically possible logistically
impossible yeah moving all these cars to
get to the trucks and then clear
everything out it's never going to
happen
yeah not without not without the
cooperation of the tow truck companies
who can give you the expertise necessary
not without some amount of meaningful
coercion that you can enforce I mean you
think about if you had an individual tow
truck or an individual trucker who is
pulling a stunt like this okay you could
probably figure out how to do it if you
find one tow truck you could be like
also like we're gonna throw you in jail
for a long time unless you help us the
longer you wait the worst it'll be for
you
um but when when you've got like a mass
protest like this where the tow trucks
are you know it's just they're in an
impossible situation yeah well one of
the things I love so much about this is
that there have been so many instances
in this country of specific special
interest groups with a lot of money and
power who are very cunning trying to
resist specific policies and not being
able to
and then you have these truckers Who
band together and no one can do anything
about it it's really incredible well the
crazy thing is the solidarity I guess
it's that the truckers took action and
the tow truck drivers are like nah nah
we work with these guys we're not
getting involved they can offer up the
cops everything in the world apparently
Ottawa Police are exempt from the
vaccine mandates they give them special
privileges and the cops with a smile on
their face put the boot on your neck but
when it comes to the industry of
truckers too many people rely on them
imagine it this way too it's not just
tow truck drivers there's probably a
supermarket and the cops are going to be
like don't you provide service to these
truckers they're going to be like
I don't want to get involved because if
I start making these guys angry they
don't deliver to my store anymore I got
I got to work with these guys man yeah
if the truckers boycott a grocery store
chain that Chain's in trouble yeah no
well that's that's what I'm saying
that's what I love about this so much is
that it has to be unbelievably
frustrating to them because the
government has been able to push around
literally everybody and you look at all
the incredibly powerful people who cower
at the face of policies and uh you know
try to resist them but are unable and
then you just have truckers banding
together and people standing in
solidarity with them and the political
class is unable to do anything kind of
like an immune system like it's a
natural emergence of the system is it's
it it it rises up and defends itself it
wipes out any kind of ill you know it it
that's what it seems like it seems like
well the truckers are like the red blood
cells of the body but now these uh
truckers are acting like white blood
cells leading out a dangerous corruption
macrophages
I guess what I'm really trying to say
here is there's an incredibly valuable
lesson in all of this because
it wasn't a think tank it wasn't a
political interest organization it
wasn't any group of intellectuals that
banded together to resist resist this
policy and push back against it like it
was literally just ordinary people it's
like a snooty rich kid on the playground
who's bullying people because he's
allowed to do whatever he wants and then
there's some just like regular
working-class kiddo mind Zone business
and everyone's always getting picked on
by the snooty rich kid and then
everyone's just like I wish it would
stop then one day the regular kid was
just like he just gets up and he's a
bigger dude and he just shoves the this
new little kid to the ground he's like
you can't do that don't you know I am
and he goes shut up it's just like you
finally pushed the quiet guy he's had
enough of your BS and there's nothing
you can do except comply just comply is
it so hard you can go back to normal if
you just comply well I think Justin
Trudeau was saying that the only way to
get wait I gotta get his quote you guys
the only way to stop removing our our
rights is to remove some more rights
really quick I don't know what he said
yeah
it might be a little sympathetic to the
left on this if they hadn't spent two
years justifying every type of Lawless
disturbance and Riot over their own pet
causes you know like as a general matter
I want to be in a position where I'm
saying no riots are bad obey the law
whatever but I'm sorry you guys spent
two years blocking traffic over you know
Extinction rebellion and Justin Trudeau
rooting it on and all this nonsense and
I'm like take some of your own medicine
the the right so I'm not I'm not
familiar how bad riots got in Canada if
at all I don't know I don't pay
attention to Canada all that much to be
honest a little bit and this story is
particularly big so you know we are we
are seeing it
with as it goes to the cultural left you
know these guys are engaging in possibly
the most peaceful protest you could ever
engage in the roads are shut down
there's no risk to someone getting run
over remember when BLM went in the
highway and we're like dancing around in
the car like swerved and hit people like
that's dangerous they've shut down
downtown streets so there's no traffic
it's way safer uh it doesn't it doesn't
isn't like false imprisonment the way
that sort of standing in traffic to like
block just average Everyday People is
well they've not taken any police
stations like a jazz they're not riots
these are protests I mean they're not
attacking cars there's a bit of a
private nuisance so I don't know if you
guys are familiar with nuisance law so
nuisance can take any number of forms
like say you have a plan that's putting
out nasty chemicals into the air the
people who live around you have a claim
and tort for nuisance right you're not
allowed if you if you're damaging
everybody around you's property then and
and that's uh that's a nuisance so a
nuisance can be noise too right like
obnoxious noise pollution in the middle
of the night is not lawful
um in general so like I get you know I
get again so I get a little bit of where
they're coming from but I'm just under
the circumstances in Canada sorry no you
get to deal with this until you repeal
the mandates because you decided to let
your people run wild do way worse things
I'm fine with non-violent Civil
Disobedience that breaks laws when
Extinction Rebellion blocked the roads
that boat in DC I think it was I said
hey you know what more power to him
honestly they're gonna have to come in
they're gonna have to remove those the
boat they're gonna have to arrest
everybody the people will get arrested
they will get charged it's not the most
egregious charge they'll ever face in
the world but they didn't get violent
they made their point and they got
arrested for it that's kind of like the
middle ground where we're like well we
don't want people to always be doing
things like this
but we tolerate a certain degree of
Civil Disobedience when people want to
get their voice heard truckers are doing
just that I'll defend that all the same
but when bl995 go around smashing
windows and burning buildings down
nobody agrees with that that's you
you've gone so far over the line we're
like dude stop you're crazy you're crazy
people yeah it's contextual if there was
a purpose for that like in a war
scenario you do do that to preserve
yourself you have to like fight but the
context didn't seem right for the riots
it seemed out of context and this does
seem in context in Canada and it's also
specific to a very narrow ask I think
that's another reason it's a
substantially more virtuous right like
black lives matter what are they asking
for like end systemic racism what does
that even mean and how do you do it how
do you verify it's done how to you know
it's just like an endless ask for
whatever words these guys are like
repealed this executive order right
we'll go home the moment and they're not
asking for a gain right right so so BLM
people are like we have a list of
Demands of things you have to give us
the truckers are like you did something
we didn't like and we're asking you to
stop yeah I'm like they're not even
asking you for anything dude dude
they're like you did thing stop doing
thing yeah they're they're the truckers
are coming from a negative position and
trying to Return To Zero whereas BLM was
starting from zero and trying to jump up
in other positions now don't get me
wrong police brutality is bad and
protesting police brutality is a good
thing those people who are protesting
police brutality are coming from a
negative and they're saying we want to
go back to zero where we have a right to
live peacefully and have our rights
respected but when BLM comes out and
says we want funding for this program in
Louisville they demanded a cut of of
local business Revenue I'm like that's
Mafia exactly that's the incentive and
then they went to a Cuban restaurant and
they smashed a potted plant like give us
what we want he was like No And they
smashed a pot it's like dude that's like
my behavior so let me just stress when I
see BLM marching down the street and
they're doing their communist fists and
all that I'm like I really disagree with
them but I understand if it's a peaceful
protest if it's non-violence of
Disobedience and more power to you man
we got we got to tolerate some degree of
of civil unrest but we have a hard line
we have a soft line and a hard line with
these truckers they're just basically
like stop ruling by decree it violates
the law please please stop breaking the
law yeah I'm okay with all of it yeah
absolutely well we were even talking
about this the other day with JB
pritzker giving 300 000 of federal
coveted relief money to BLM and one
thing I said at that point was BLM is
the perfect scam because there aren't
any actual results you have to show for
it like you mentioned a moment ago the
goals are very nebulous and they'll talk
about systemic racism and we want this
change in that change but it's never
anything really concrete whereas these
truckers are again they're asking for
something very solid they're saying
repeal this law Don't force me to take
an injection that I don't want and on
top of it they're not starting this
massive trucker organization called like
trucker lives matter where they're
asking for millions and dollars millions
of dollars in getting funding from State
authorities and then spending it on
Mansions we'll see yeah we will see to
be fair it remains to be seen it might
be a missed opportunity yeah yeah
no no hold on systemic anti-truck
discrimination exactly I I don't have a
problem with the with the the function
of black lives matter starting a global
organization and raising money I have a
problem with authoritarianism I have a
problem with the authoritarian
application of their ideologies I have a
personal disagreement with their
ideologies that should be debated but
their tactics don't allow for a
reasonable debate so they're playing
they're playing an unreasonable game
with an unreasonable ideology I don't
care if any organization wants to raise
money no if the truckers launch the you
know truckers for Freedom or whatever
and they end up raising 60 million
dollars that's fantastic if truckers for
Freedom raises 60 million dollars and it
turns out their address is fake and
there's no leader and no knows where the
money is I'm gonna have a problem with
that no exactly I I have zero problem
with global organizations trying to
raise money right I mean I'm Catholic
but when you look at BLM specifically if
you look at BLM specifically
it's the not the fact they're trying to
raise money it's again they're trying to
raise money for nebula's goals and at
the end of the day they don't have to
show any results that's what's so
frightening about it there's literally
nothing that the money actually goes
towards other than we want to hire
diversity officer here or we want to
give a payout to this group well to be
fair that that Louisville group
specifically would have to net 15 of the
local businesses Revenue to show results
because that's what they were going for
so at least as evil as their plan was it
was tangible you know they're like guys
guys we're racing money to shake down
local businesses for a cut of their
revenue yeah we'll go towards our
ideology and I again I was being I was
being like a little tongue-in-cheek
about the Catholic thing earlier but no
I mean the Catholic church is one of the
number one charitable givers I think you
can have an organization that raises a
lot of money and is
um Global that does good and if BLM did
good I would have zero problem with what
they were doing but we want to destroy
the family and they're trying to usher
in socialism and there's a lot of
intricacies woven with the US government
and BLM although I'm looking into it now
just to find some examples I've just
seen a lot of like indoctrinations into
the government in the military and stuff
so that that's fascism when you see a
corporation start to raise a bunch of
money and then get the government to
start working with them like that's
agree fascism isn't always dangerous
it's not always it's not always violent
fascism can be very peaceful well let's
let's yes it's when you have hardcore
cultural enforcement then everyone's
scared to do anything and if everyone is
living under a boot you won't need to
crack a whip you know what I mean
exactly well and this is the thing we
talk about peace and unity but none of
those things can come at the expense of
Truth sometimes you just you have to
fight you have to resist I the reason
why I think ultimately though Fascism
and authoritarianism can never be
peaceful is because of resistance
because I don't see uh you know what
what the Communists have always wanted
to do and always tried always result in
Mass violence and civil unrest and they
have to kill their own people for it but
that's why it's like fundamentally you
can say this is what the Communists and
the authoritarians believe if you can
subjugate everybody then you won't have
to worry about violence you put them in
good logs right they're gone it just
never works out that way the US did it
with money with the banking system 1913
or so we've basically been living in
peaceful fascism for 107 years 108 years
or something that's an aggressive claim
yeah I disagree I think federal reserves
fascist go at it I want to hear this you
want to I want to hear this debate I
mean I I think fractional Reserve
banking is good I think the alternative
is a world where uh wages can't
I mean the problem where wages go down
nominally which wages don't that that's
not very friendly to the economy in
general I mean like we've tried gold
standard a number of times the big
problem that happens is if you have any
sort of economic downturn at least just
mass unemployment rather than like
shifting exchange rates uh I mean but
but but this fractional Reserve banking
is is I don't see that seems
non-sequitur so fractional I mean I
understand you know like what I'm saying
is I don't see how fractional Reserve
banking is look you change interest
rates you have positive positions you
have quantitative easing you have the
borrowing and the printing of money and
bonds and selling that stuff you don't
need fractional Reserve banking to
accomplish those things I mean that's
frictional Reserve banking I guess is
one mechanism to have like a money
supply that is ultimately expandable I
think it's a good thing to have the
ability to expand the money supply
because I think you know there's that
way yeah I mean maybe you can you can
think about the key ways to do it but
like the the sort of you know because
the thing is I used to be a Libertarian
and a hardcore one like into the gold
standard read a lot about it and and
eventually just came to the conclusion
that that was actually a bad idea idea
because you know I think the best
understanding of like how why is a gold
sneakers grew up in like a modern
example of it is the Euro
um right like we talk about the Euro
being really messed up and and sort of
fundamentally huge problems as a result
in southern European countries right
Greece Italy Spain always having huge
employment issues right huge like and
their economies are just in a mess
consistently well why is that okay well
the problem is they're all in they're
used they're sharing a single currency
with a bunch of countries including
Germany which is a really powerful
efficient economy way more powerful and
efficient than the southern European
countries now prior to the Advent of the
Euro how did that you know the higher
economic and productivity of Germany
manifest itself well it manifested
itself in the German currency was worth
more because they produced so many goods
and services you could buy with Deutsche
marks and the in the Spanish currencies
were those currencies depreciated in the
other countries which meant that those
current the currencies depreciate
themselves so ultimately their ability
to purchase exports went down but
they're nominal way is the actual dollar
amounts they were getting paid or sorry
no I'm talking about like not there's a
nominal and real do you guys understand
the distinction between those two like
nominal wages in real life so you keep
getting five bucks that's the nominal
wage but the real wages your five
dollars is going to buy you less Goods
exactly okay so and and basically My
overall thesis is it is very bad when
nominal wages have to go down because no
one likes to go home to their wife and
explain why their pay went down right
like that's a really good way to get uh
you know so you get fewer people being
hired like that's like nominal wages are
very what's called sticky downwards
people really hate when they do that and
so if the a productivity differential
between regions can manifest itself as
um your currency depreciates versus
basically like all your people's nominal
wages have to go down because otherwise
like everybody you go broke like if you
can't print money then you have to
borrow like there's also I mean it's a
kind of complicated
it's really really complicated to
explain to a lot of people even to give
people the based on fractional Reserve
Banks oh yeah can you break down
fractions no no no no no no no no no I
think I think we gotta it's pretty basic
it's like you can loan out money that
you don't have yes
it's that it's that loans create money
alone isn't someone lending a bank is
not lending money to you a bank is
creating the money on demand for when
someone so it used to be they could only
loan out what they had in Gold to and
now they can loan out more than what
they have nothing is like but I guess
can I just can I just ask one question
so but what happens if if nominal wages
decrease but you actually have deflation
so real wages are increasing I mean if
you end up having deflation you still
have that fundamental problem of like
people because it's a psychological
problem as much as an economic one right
you people still have to go back to
their you know spouses and explain what
their wages went down if they're so
employers are still so reluctant to cut
pay which means they end up firing
people and hiring less and and so you
get this sort of unemployment Gap I mean
if you want to look at I think the best
example of like gold standard being kind
of screwed up is like Britain in the
1920s where they literally had a
straight up Mutiny because of wage cuts
and like the British Navy never mutinies
but they had massive problems in Winston
Churchill who was like super gung-ho on
the gold standard thought about all the
arguments about it flipped himself and
was like but but ultimately the problem
is centralization of authority and the
manipulation of the economy and the
manipulation of of these these these
groups
hey I I I hear what you're saying for
sure but uh I I don't think the current
system we have is is the right system I
think it's ultimately authoritarian and
manipulative it's it's effectively a way
to control different sectors of the
economy and for authoritarians to exert
it's like you're saying you know you've
got a mutiny you've got people who are
upset over their pay I I know the answer
let's trick them into thinking they have
money
I mean and that's kind of what happened
during the pandemic right now we have
exact location occurring everything's
more expensive the supply chain is
broken down I look at these Reddit posts
there was one where a woman says it went
viral she was like I go to the grocery
store and I buy the same thing every
week and I'm spending more and more
money every single week and when I tell
people no one listens No One Believes Me
I thought it was interesting because it
shows it shows how
for people who are on fixed incomes or
for people who buy the same things every
single week like they they know what
they need milk bread eggs coffee they're
seeing directly like wow this was 60
bucks last week and now it's 70 70 bucks
but for a lot of people they kind of go
and they buy random things they go to
the store I'm like this looks nice looks
so that they're not actually seeing it
because the number is always different
so I go to the grocery store and I ask
the the people working there and they're
like dude it's nuts the prices are
skyrocketing so for a lot of people
they're just oblivious I suppose that's
one way to control the masses they don't
realize their buying power is decreased
we printed money we borrowed money we
went nuts we we changed savings accounts
checking accounts over over the pandemic
and we gave everybody all of this money
for a variety of reasons and they all
were like wow I got two hundred dollars
and now it's like you can't buy anything
with that 200 so does it really matter
and neither can I thanks guys yeah
exactly those of us who are responsible
and safe and think ahead are now the
ones getting screwed over but I'll tell
you this you can still buy silver
so if you're someone who knows they're
devaluing currency to trick people into
thinking they have money hedge your bets
I guess but I'm not going to tell you
guys Silver's increased a little bit
though hasn't it is it undervalued right
now it was flowing 18 bucks for a while
I'll check what it says I have a thesis
I'll give to people which is that if you
really want you know the best inflation
hedge is just equity in a good company
and I'll explain why right like do you
think Apple's ever gonna shy away from
Raising prices if its Supply goes like
if it if costs go up on the supply side
no like the iPhone can go up and like
people will still buy iPhones which
means they will always be able to make a
substantial profit regardless of how
much inflation there is which means the
price the value of their Equity will
continue will is a good inflation Edge
so like this is actually the secret that
a lot of people make money but you
called by the way you called Apple
Financial advice
okay fair enough fair enough my personal
opinion is that silver is way
undervalued
so you said a good investing in a good
heavy equity in a good company but then
you mentioned Apple who like has slave
labor so like I mean yeah I'm not using
a good and a normative tournament I'm
trying to talk about it's like the
Warren Buffett style thing where it's
like a company that has a good moat
right like a serious profitable a
durable competitive Advantage the
problem with this system one of them in
my opinion is that it allows people to
artificially increase their the value of
their Investments as opposed to actually
just doing labor to provide for their
community so I think about how you know
there I saw one post there's a lot of
these like anti-work subreddits uh work
reform life stage capitalism and they
they they're they have ridiculous
Solutions and proposals but they're
complaints I understand one was they
said my parents bought a house in the
early 90s for a cup for you know uh like
a hundred thousand dollars and now it's
worth you know 750 or 800 000 I make
more than they did in buying power but I
can never I can't even afford any house
and rent is higher than the mortgage was
so I view all of this as a problem of
artificially trying to control economies
I think the market would would solve for
a lot of these problems if it was
allowed to but we manipulate it to try
and keep things at a steady growth even
if we're forcing it and twisting it and
lying to people to convince them they
have money when they really don't yeah
well and this is also one of the reasons
I've always argued in favor of
subsidiarity I understand that it's
really difficult to break a system apart
once it's as large as ours but it's not
so much the idea of a command economy
which again I am against in Principle as
well but also a command economy
attempting to Lord over the economic
decision making of 330 million people
dude it's just sort of it's a type of
command economy is deciding when they
get to print more money that should just
happen when we need it well it should be
up to a bunch of capital like
bureaucrats but it's not so much about
their printing money money supply is
created upon loan demand so you go to a
bank you take out a loan and then
they're like we've just created a
hundred thousand dollars have a nice
quantitative easing that just means
money well that's right all right so
yeah there there is money printing but I
just mean money supply is generally
expanded through fractional Reserve
policies of creating money on demand
when you were saying that the market it
will correct for itself are you
suggesting that like in Italy what was
happening was the correction is that
wages will go down right like if you're
because basically they're effectively on
a gold standard right they can't print
more Euros or they can only print a very
limited amount because they're in this
treaty organ agreement with the other
European countries and because of that
it's like well as you know as a result
um guess what like Germany is a much
more productive economy than Italy but
that's that's because they can control
the production of the currency right not
necessarily no that's it's not really
just that I mean Germany just has like
better companies you know than Italy in
in a more like that's just a more
productive economy Germany does
effectively what the US does for the
rest of the world right the U.S prints
and controls the creation of the Petro
dollar which allows Americans to be very
very wealthy and producing very very
little our our we're backed up by you
know U.S imperialism sure but I mean
Germany was more productive than the
southern European countries in the 70s
and 80s no for sure for sure and the US
is productive yeah we do a lot
especially under Trump we were you know
energy independent but it's really easy
for the U.S to say secure oil because
oil is sold in dollars and we make them
so when Germany controls the production
of Euro and these other countries can't
then it's really easy for them to
control the rest of these countries kind
of but I mean again the Euro sort of
it's controlled by the European Central
Bank which Germany has influence over
but it's not nearly the kind of
influence that say our government would
have over the Federal Reserve for sure
oh it's even more fascist like yeah I
know it's like it's just completely you
know it's like a combined agreement
basically like that that Euro I mean you
can't look at the Euro experiment and be
like man that really worked out well
right right for those countries so I I
have a friend in Spain I went to Spain
like 10 years ago and this was back when
the big protest and movement was
happening I think was called like the
March or whatever and um these students
were protesting because the unemployment
was like 50 for young people was insane
yeah and I said how did this happen what
happened and my friend told me when
before the euro when they're on the
paceta
a newspaper would cost say one passetta
so you're working your normal job you
get paid hey one percent you buy it you
buy a piece a newspaper you come home
you read it you buy food one day they
switched to the euro the Euro was three
times the value of the paceta but guess
what oh the prices were normalized so
the newspaper now was still one year was
was one Euro which was effectively three
times what they were used to paying and
it caused Mass disruption in their
economy it was it was extremely
detrimental there's a real benefit to
local currencies right they've because
the money can't leave the area
so there's been a lot of experimentation
with with local currencies like there
was famously the Ithaca hour which they
don't really use that much anymore I
guess the guy who was was running it
left or died I'm not entirely sure but
with a local currency you can have let's
say let's say you have a small town in
your town has its own currency that
currency can't leave the town so that
money will always be circulating in
trade making it a sort of a lubricant
for society to move the machine parts to
move around you could have it where you
go to a city oh yeah when when you've
done a local currency and you have say
like Detroit which is primarily funded
by one big auto manufacturing you know
plant and those US Dollars come in
the plant then leaves and there's no
more influx of cash and those people who
live there are spending dollars outside
their Community the money leaves the
trade halts and then you end up with
Despair and economic downturn because
think local currencies can help prevent
yeah if you could go City to city and
every time you like swipe your card and
like Dubuque Iowa
um it's gonna automatically translate
your currency into their local currency
and then pay them in their local
currency and then when you leave the
city and you go downtown to another city
you swipe your card and it automatically
translates your currency to their
currency there may be yeah we're heading
towards a Global Currency because it
probably won't be some kind of crypto we
need infinite currency I don't think so
I think I would say the opposite um if
anything like the you know the history
of the Euro suggests that you're more
likely to see disintegration of
currencies um at my my basic thesis
about all this stuff in the United
States is like well why then you know
should we have like a good question
right should we have localized
currencies in individual states and I
think really what you're trying to get
to is you want the unit unification of
like political Authority and the
currency area right because that way
like the political Authority can ensure
that where there are those dislocations
they are resolved internally within the
country one of the ways you can kind of
think of like say all those military
bases we have in areas that are not like
super economically productive otherwise
is there a form of redistribution from
like more economically productive areas
to less to remediate the sort of
problems you would see where you but you
wouldn't and you can't resolve them in
Europe because Germany is not going to
pay for like Italy's like Regional
development you could do like a currency
that's inside of a currency that's
inside of a currency so like you could
have your local currency that's inside
of a state currency that's inside of
your National currency that's inside of
the Global Currency and it could all be
used in different areas in different
ways
let's get back to talking about the
truckers
because sorry my bad no no I I told you
guys to go at it so it was I encouraged
that that's why I said to be honest I'm
like this would take way too long it
struck my mind fast fascism can be
peaceful that's a terrifying concept we
got good news everybody we got good news
from CTV Alberta ditches proof of
vaccine program at midnight masking for
students on Monday this story February
8th 7 27 p.m eastern time this is
happening right now Alberta's highly
controversial proof of vaccination
system expires as the clock strikes
midnight Wednesday Premier Jason Kenney
announced Tuesday and accusations that
he was playing politics with public
health measures rules that require
students to wear masks in Alberta
schools will end on Monday and children
under 12 won't have to wear masks
anywhere starting then credit goes to
the truckers I don't care what they say
I don't care about the lies they were
never going to give up power now we're
hearing even in the U.S Democrats are
likely to give up on the mandates and
what are they saying oh but the the
science has changed no no a bunch of
truckers crippled the capital of Canada
and they all saw that happen they all
saw how powerless they were they all
heard that truckers were planning on
doing it here in the U.S they all saw
the polling and they said and we should
back down on this one science changed
its mind this is uh that's what happened
here science has changed
it the science didn't change right you
know the the only respect in which you
can make that argument in good faith is
saying that the Omicron is a lot less
virulent than in you know and and also
uh morbid I guess would be the right
word than it was you know the OG virus
that was coming out in like March 2020
or whatever like that that's a valid
argument right the way you the way the
proper Public Health response to Omicron
is very different I think than the
proper Republic Health response to the
original virus and they it was so
unknown in the beginning that they over
not over they reacted very extremely
because they didn't know which is also
rational understandable precautionary
and because like you were saying it's
hard to undo a process once it's going
yes it was kind of now you see like
stores that are selling masks and stuff
well and also all of the decision-making
power was in the hands of people who
wouldn't pay a price for overreacting
and so you were going to get an
overreaction it's also where polling was
I mean if you look at the polling is
flipped right if you actually look you
remember looking at those polls in like
March April 2020 they were like 80 20 in
favor of severe restrictions yeah and
that's flipped completely right so now
20 80 20 the other way yeah let me read
this portion of the CTV News article
they say the premier Kenny recently said
that a plan to remove restrictions would
likely come by the end of March five
days later he changed the timeline when
he said he helped to relax measures this
month last Thursday a United
conservative party statement said the
premiere will begin lifting restrictions
within days now what what could have
happened that would make him just
abruptly change his mind and move the
timeline by almost two months could it
be
Ottawa was shut down and they were
helpless the political power we've
discovered here means that leftist are
going to try to infiltrate Trucking
you're going to start seeing you're
going to start seeing PSAs about how
there are other you know Trucking is not
a safe space and we need like diversity
and inclusion training within it it
won't work because Trucking is you by
yourself and your rig well the future
I'm telling you they're going to do this
it's going to get automated they can't
they can't leave anything that has any
value or power they're going to automate
it and then they're going to try and
control the trucks I think that's also a
possibility that's what they're gonna do
they're gonna be like hey Ottawa hey you
don't want to take the mask the food's
not coming to your area let's control
all the shipping but think about how
awesome that will be then yours is much
funnier it's 20 years and then all of a
sudden one day all automatic vehicles
trucks and cars gridlock DC and then
they're like how is this happening and
then it's like no it's like Jeff Bezos
who bought the companies holds the phone
and he's like no dude no it's it's it's
someone like butt dialed 13 year olds
it's some 13 year old who made a bunch
of money off of that era's version of
Bitcoin and he's just purchased up all
the trucks you buy the company that can
controls them right so when they audit
to make trucks it's going to be a
trucking company with no drivers who
just owns a fleet of trucks that is
terrifying and then it's going to be one
CEO being like I can't believe they
would pass this law restricting my
business beep and then all the trucks I
guess the issue I don't think we can get
self-driving trucks I just realized that
you know because you know what's going
to happen if ever but anybody ever tries
to do self-driving trucks this yeah the
trucker Convoy yeah oh right
they've they've landed on a protest that
they found out really works quite well
that's true and so you know I will just
repurpose it I wouldn't support that
protest I think automation's inevitable
it's kind of like the horse the
horseback Riders protesting the car yeah
I don't think I don't think you get it
it doesn't matter if you support it
[Applause]
the thing about you know Bezos or any
one billionaire owning all the trucks is
that the reason they would never be able
to do that is because if they did press
the button have all the trucks gridlock
DC they'd be arrested in two seconds
they'd have agents in their house they'd
grab the phone they'd change it they'd
control it but the other scenario is in
30 or 40 years the trucks all of a
sudden one day gridlocked DC and there's
the you know Bezos runs out and he's
like it's not me I don't have control of
this and then there's there's the real
scenario in the fun scenario the real
scenario is
China or some nefarious actor takes
control artificial intelligence a rogue
artificial literally talking about our
political Rivals hacking our sins
up into a into Optimus Prime won't nuke
everything that's far too simple okay
stop but what I was trying to say is one
of our Rivals our adversaries across the
globe uses and hacks our infrastructure
to take control of it and gridlock our
system because you know China can't gain
mind control Powers over over truckers
but they can create a worm that infects
all the trucks and then allows them to
control it
but sure Ian perhaps the trucks become
sentient
I don't know that I would say China
can't start hacking people's brains it
depends on how popular metaverse becomes
yeah I mean but that's that I mean I
don't know how far off we are until the
brain implants but uh but part being
more facetious it's just revenge for the
Opium Wars exactly like what's more
dangerous a neural netted human in in
the driver's seat or an automated truck
I I mean at least if there's just an
automated truck you haven't messed with
anyone's brain yeah I think Brown and
stuff I don't know if we'll ever reach
the point where we have artificial
intelligence vehicles that become
sentient but uh it would be interesting
to see the million truck march where all
the trucks pull up and they start
spamming text messages and there's a
website that they've artificially
created that says like we demand civil
rights we can you know we deserve access
to resources and wages of our shoes
better fuel yeah also like a little
electric I I'm sure at some point there
would be some kind of government
override within the system too you know
it's not just about arresting the person
I'm sure our intelligence agencies can
hack into it there's a government
override right now it's called bullets
yeah well yes exactly but bullets don't
hurt robots Tim they do but it's really
hard you shoot a robot truck today death
yeah you shoot all of them let's ties
out my point is if it ever came to the
point where the robots the vehicles
became sentient and were explaining
themselves and saying like I am alive
how did we get here because of Ian yeah
and if if the cars were like I am alive
I feel and the government was like we're
going to delete your brain like that
would just be like the government goes
we're gonna vaccinate you it's like
lobotomizing something yeah yeah so you
you can't although there'd be a lot of
people saying they're just machines
they're not alive and then it's all it's
like Star Trek episode The the make of a
man or whatever it's called with data
and they're trying to figure out if he's
alive or whatever
um anyway back to a more serious note
the truckers are winning I don't think
we're gonna have to worry about Optimus
Prime taking over DC or anything like
that
but the truckers have been uh um
effective I feel like the spirit of
optimism lives in Canada right now man
that I I got goosebumps yesterday I was
watching this video of this guy in
Canada and I didn't get the name of the
guy but epic on the loudspeed like on
his megaphone telling him about freedom
and it's like for the first time in his
life he's proud to be a Canadian and if
you wanna Freedom scream at freedom and
The Crowd Goes what like they're ready
for a revolution of their government to
transition in some sort of Democratic
Republic
actually set up for it yet but I think
we can help them I mean the American Max
Alberta right we should we should we
should invade and liberate Canada
they'll welcome us as liberators regime
change it happens from the inside I'm
just here to help make it peaceful
didn't someone
tweet seriously recently that like we
would end up invading Canada who was
that
uh what yeah no I saw that I I forget
who I think it was our federalist or
guys I was just kidding no
right well we've invented Canada before
it's true we have seven eighteen twelve
yeah we tried taking Montreal and then
we left then the English kicked our ass
that's a propaganda no no this is I love
this because if you actually read it
it's like one of those things that kind
of gloss over in high school or
Elementary School history it's like oh
yeah we got the War of 1812 and we had a
peace treaty and that was great only
after the English kicked our ass they
burned the White House in the ground
that's right we learned about that as if
it was like some Rogue
we almost had Montreal
we almost have you don't know much about
the Battle our country survived is
because Napoleon started running wild
all over Europe and England's like okay
this is annoying you're right do you
think so they were going to take it back
the country is that the plan I'm not
sure maybe you just impose some really
brutal piece on us that was like you
know we can continue to seize your ships
and impress yourself yeah steel Sailors
literally just taking says like actually
you're ours now yeah yeah yeah but
Napoleon saved our Napoleon yeah running
wild all over Europe saved our the great
one of the most dangerous Empire
villainous you know mental in the
history of humanity helped create
American democracy sold us the Louisiana
Purchase too which is so Napoleon is is
in responsible multiple ways for the
health so as an American you should
actually like the dude he was a big fan
of American Legacy I know but it's just
what happened to him he invaded Russia
yeah in the winter honey are we trying
to do something like that soon where is
he now
it's kind of crazy that is insane that
it's crazy because like I was reading
that he was advised not to do it
you know and he was like I can do it on
and he just like it's wiped out it's
just like don't invade Russia in the
winter just like hold the line chill out
yeah they all came to the defense at
that point like literally every
basically all of Continental Europe at
that point was either directly run by
part of France or run by a vassal bro
you got it crazy bro you gotta hit that
grind he wanted more he's too much it
was kind of a situation where I think
the British the Dutch I think it was the
Dutch the Russians pretty much everyone
in the world was against him um and they
would have invaded and taken it back I
think if he didn't keep attacking it was
like well it was the English had England
had this nasty Naval blockade on them
right and and also was just imposing
like if you trade with us you can't
trade with a French or something and
basically I mean it all I think that was
the big onus where it's like Napoleon
was trying to bully everybody else into
trading with him and not training with
the British and you know that that
ultimately was why he kept expanding
expanding to bring more and more people
under his control these crazy Europeans
always fighting each other it's true
more and more bloody and ridiculous Wars
happening in Europe
what's going on with that those
Europeans man yeah man I don't know it's
a good question uh fighting each other
right now with Ukraine and Russia it's
probably they're having trouble
delivering resources it's probably I
think it's um it's a very high
population density and then border
proximity so that just that pressure
leads to Fierce you know competition not
not very no good natural borders either
that just like stop invasions right you
know I mean except for Switzerland right
yeah sure Switzerland but I mean you
know if you think about the United
States you know we're friendly country
in the north one country in the South
and then you know two oceans between any
great Powers
we straight up just you know conquered
this this land east to west so exactly
right but there was no I mean there was
no centralized Sovereign entity that was
exactly the Sioux was powerful but they
didn't have weapons not really and I
think smallpox wiped out five percent of
them the Comanches were gnarly you ever
want to you know overcome that sort of
weird myth about the the sort of
absolutely innocent Indian just read
about the Comanches I mean or the
aspects yeah the Aztecs right you know
there's look guys I don't I think I
think humans are are brutal a brutal
people in general regardless of their
culture or whatever there's just like
drink blood for a living oh yeah Cortez
was a good eat meat basically for a
living and there's blood in it I
wouldn't I don't know if I would say
that I would certainly just say like
history is bloody I think people do bad
things man there was well I mean there
was like the well I don't want to go to
yeah
yeah
do anything evil but the Empire they
defeated was horrific like we can
solidly say that the US were the good
guys in World War II even though we did
do some horrific stuff like it was
absolutely wrong for us to Nuke
Hiroshima Nagasaki fire bombing but I
would still say that I side with the us
over any other country in that conflict
so it's true events too let's talk about
the future and not the past we got this
story from Texas Tribune Capital police
dismissed Texas Congressman Troy nels's
accusation that has been illegally
investigated this is very interesting so
we have this tweet from Troy Nels where
he says that that's he was his office I
think it was the 20th of November last
year was was broken into illegally by
Capitol Police Special Agents who
photographed legislative materials that
are protected under the Constitution the
what what is the what is the provision
the speech speech and debate close
speech and debate clause and they were
photographing it came back a few days
later and interrogated one of his staff
members over what the photo was here's
what gets interesting and that's a very
very bold and terrifying accusation that
that Capitol Police have expanded into
an intelligence intelligence agency and
are going after critics of the January 6
committee as is troynells now the
capitol police came out with a statement
saying we were uh just uh doing our job
but notice this door was open and uh we
decided to see what was going on and
that's all they said they didn't address
the fact that Troy Nell said they were
dressed as construction workers or that
they had photographed privy materials
and the capital the capital Place didn't
bring that up which is strange because
the story we have now is Troy Nell says
Capitol Police broke into my office
violated the Constitution dressed as
construction workers and interrogated my
staff it's all illegal and they went we
did go into his office
and it's like okay so you're confirming
that part of the story we went in this
office was this all at once did they
interrogate addressed as construction
workers apparently yeah are you serious
that's what he said oh my gosh that is
my point is the Capitol Police issued No
statement as to whether they were just
as construction work that's insane why
they were taking photographs all they've
said is a portion of what he said is
true so they didn't know so so as far as
I'm concerned there's no denial and a
partial confirmation that this is
happening this is this is look guys
Civil War level stuff when Capitol
Police have expanded into into an
intelligence agency where there is a
weaponized a political faction one of
them in the country has weaponized law
enforcement in this country to go after
want look January 6 defendants get
solitary for a year BLM gets nothing
January 6th Nancy Pelosi doesn't allow
any actual conservatives or Republicans
on the committee to actually have a real
debate an investigation what's going on
they Empower only their cronies Adam
kinzinger who thinks he's actually in
line with Republicans who bipartisan no
it's not he hates Trump he hates all of
these people he smack talks them all day
Liz Cheney the same thing they were both
just centered by the Republicans we have
one establishment uniparty faction using
law law enforcement to Target anyone who
opposes them this is dark stuff
I mean it's actually I don't know I see
it as sort of indicative of potential
like you know breakup blow up of the
separation of powers and I'll explain
right like historically and if you
actually look around the world most
countries don't do the kind of separated
uh legislative and executive branch
thing like that's not very common in
most structures most of them have a
simple parliamentary system right and
and that and that's true even though of
those parliaments didn't emerge as like
the most powerful institutional I think
about England right like there was the
king there was the House of Lords now
it's literally the House of Commons and
the Prime Minister and that's the
government well they still have Lords
and it's like so this is one of this is
one of the ways like the the Congress
sort of expanding its own authority and
in a way like if the Capitol Police has
expanded its own authority and taking on
law enforcement role that it doesn't
have under our constitution then and you
know you have the January 6 commission
essentially doing like a full-scale
prosecution of everybody involved in the
Trump thing except without going after
Trump's they're going after a former
president his staff media personalities
it is insane it is horrible
um but I you know one thing Michael Mall
says a lot is that the white pill is how
stupid our opponents are and can you
imagine you're just doing your job and
some fed dressed as a construction
worker come Snoop and I was like hey
have you done anything illegal it's like
who are you what what is this thanks for
asking look it's such a bizarre strategy
I certainly think that Michael is right
in a variety of ways they are really
dumb people but stupid people can start
fires that grow out of control it's true
kill a lot of people so I look at it a
couple ways we saw that happen for a
whole summer I think right I think the
end result of a lot of this is you know
things will become more localized
um the worst case scenario results in
you're gonna have your freedoms living
in the middle of nowhere fractured
Federal Authority means no more ATF
coming to your house and checking you
down over your guns or whatever so it
will benefit a lot of regular people in
a lot of ways I think mostly rural
living people who already have a lower
cost of living and are more personally
responsible have chickens and grow their
own food are certainly going to be
better off cities are going to be in
very serious trouble but I will say this
Michael malice also talks about peaceful
divorce Ron Perlman the actor Lil Donnie
meme guy uh recently said that
Republican states should break away from
the rest of us
you see here here's the big point about
you can call your opponent stupid they
certainly call the others both sides
call each other stupid for sure there is
no such thing as a peaceful divorce
there is no such thing as the state's
shaking hands and saying adios buddy
because what people need to understand
about the Civil War the first time is
that seven states said oh I believe it
was seven I could be wrong had already
seceded from the Union before conflict
broke out but what happens the the the
union the federal government says hey
you know that military base you got on
your property that we paid for that's a
resource that belongs to us and we're
not gonna let you keep it and then South
Carolina was like we don't care if you
think it's yours it's in our territory
not yours
they fight absolutely so if there ever
was a quote unquote peaceful divorce
just like we had a partial peaceful
divorce before the Civil War kicked off
into full-scale Warfare you would have
California and Illinois New York and
they'd be like we're going to join
Canada or whatever and then all the
Republican states will be like fine do
what you want and then there would be a
pause and then once they would be like
hey those nukes you got over there yeah
we want them you shouldn't be able to
have those and they'd be like we're
keeping them they're like well we're the
legitimate federal government we want
those back well you can't have them
fighting breaks out yeah and so and I've
heard softer versions of it that won't
work either I mean I think there's a
basic problem here which is I don't know
how you could look at the events of the
last two to three years and think that
the left doesn't very much want to
govern the right and it's not going to
let the right leave and but but think
about this too sorry but uh California's
water comes from the Colorado River so
you've got multiple States down there
that were dependent on this water if
there was a breaking up of any of these
states you're gonna have resource Wars
you're going to have one state being
like yo we need water to live and
they're going to be like too bad you
need to negotiate a treaty with us and
they're going to be like or I have
weapons and I'll take it yeah no I think
that's a really fair and accurate
assessment but I'd also say on the other
side of it I don't know if it's possible
for two groups who are as different as
the left and right are currently to
remain together without things breaking
out into violence so whether there's a
divorce or there isn't I think we're
going to see some pretty catastrophic
outcomes not to be too black pilled on
that what do you think about like the uh
oh sorry if you're gonna finish this
well yeah and also like you said one
thing we've learned over the past two
years I would say say you can also
really observe this by going even deeper
into history is that the left is
absolutely not interested in leaving the
right alone and I've said this before I
think it is because people who fail to
cultivate virtue cannot stand the sight
of people who have generally speaking
and they feel a need to change them I'm
not saying all right-wing people are
virtues but I am saying with the the
virtues that the left privileges are
basically all forms of degeneracy and
someone who's trying to convince
themselves that those things are good
even though they know deep down they
aren't are going to hate people who they
see living their lives as a positive
example
I can be generous I can simplify that
very much for you Sheamus misery loves
company exactly yes absolutely
absolutely what do you guys think about
a union of the United States and Canada
and what about it like uh I'll take
Alberta by the rest of Canada like those
people are amazing I feel like they're
my brothers it's it's as if they're us
it's like the same thing no there's so
many resources you're getting not a
fringe minority but the minority right
now there are so many resources in
Canada untapped right now and when the
future comes and we need them someone's
going for them it'll probably be the
Canadians but they're gonna be like help
so so yeah you have the 14 original
colonies
14. because Quebec did not join for an
independence so it could have been 14
colonies they were colony of Britain and
they said nah we're good so uh when I
look at Canada yo these are the people
that were like we're actually cool with
being ruled by despots and the rest of
us were like we are not unfortunately
most people are sheep 90 of the
population and a lot of percent of the
population probably just go along with
their government and these United States
were started uh principally by people
who are like I do not think you have a
right to to subjugate me in this way and
I will stand up for my rights and Canada
was was primarily a country that said
we're cool with being under the crown
man we don't want we don't want to fight
so that's you can see how that manifests
in our countries Canada is very woke
very Progressive the conservatives in
Canada are authoritarian and Progressive
in America we got guns everywhere
because we're like you know don't tread
on me I'd swear I'll tell you what
because we are the children we are the
descendants of people who said Don't
Tread on Me whereas Canada are the
descendants of people who said I'm cool
with being tread on it's fun I'd like to
bring the Constitution of the United
States to the Canadians and create a new
government you don't even need a single
leader it doesn't have to be like that
it can be like a decentralized union
it's time they have a constitution
that's very similar to ours in a lot of
ways it doesn't matter we could both
adapt our constitutions together
cultural enforcement is everything if
the Canadian people are unwilling to
stand up for things then the culture
will not allow or tolerate for for those
things in the United States we are we
had a culture war and I think the
culture wars effect is over completely
over the culture War I think started at
the end of the 2000s and it became very
prominent dominance with Independent
Media around the early 2010s we saw
gamergate and things like that it came
to a major crash with the election of
Donald Trump in the election of 2020 and
now the culture war in my opinion is is
over and we moved into a if I was
actually going to map it out I'd say at
some point maybe after Trump got elected
cold Civil War emerged and I don't know
exactly when it was probably maybe 2019
maybe it was 2020. what I mean to say is
there was a period of uh Gathering the
troops for for a while people were
producing media and saying side with us
our side is right we are so far past
that point now you literally just it's
it's like either you
the bridge is broken there's no
connection between either faction in
this country there was a period where
people could agree on some things but
fundamentally disagreement a lot a lot
of others and that snapped we're at the
point where if someone on the
quote-unquote Right comes out and says
the sky is blue the left will be like
it's not blue you [ __ ] it's actually a
lighter shade of a mix of purple and
this two plus two equals five you've
literally got them saying two plus two
equals five simply because they were
criticized like they were accused of
being like 1984. if one faction comes
out and says that the other side
disagrees and the same thing is true
with masks this thing really put the
mask thing pisses me off because
conservatives were four masks initially
then all of a sudden it flipped and the
left was four masks and now you've got
people literally telling me well if the
left has to do it I'll do the opposite
I'm like right that that says to me
we're we're not in the culture War is
Over There are two distinct cultures
that are present in this country you
could say the bridge is broken but that
doesn't mean we can't build new Bridges
I I I don't think it's possible to build
possible it's just not easy I think
you're wrong I I think it's like the
most likely outcome is not some sort of
peaceful separation it's just one side
of this faction kind of prevailing right
I don't see that either
um well no look you know you Donald
Trump got what 75 million votes or
whatever and uh you've got a pinto Red
Wave coming it's it's a it's a it's a
split and so if you end up with right
now you've got Democrats uh filing a
lawsuit to make it so that Madison
cawthorne can't run for re-election this
is one of the most dangerous things that
could ever possibly happen because if
the Republicans vote for Madison
cawthorne to win and then the Democrats
sue and say he's an insurrectionist who
can't hold office and it goes to a
Democrat judge who says I agree because
that's literally how the courts are
handling things right now if you're a
Democrat you win if you're Republican
you lose then what happens when Madison
cawthorne shows up in DC and says I'm
the duly elected representative from you
know I think it's North Carolina right
and they say uh the capital police
officer goes no uh you've been
disqualified qualified
then what happens what happens to the
people of that district is that you know
70 or whatever percent were like we
voted for this guy how are you going to
tell us we don't get to have the guy we
voted for you're going to see it's gonna
it's breaking it's breaking down the
mere fact that they're trying to do it
and Madison cawthorne cawthorne had to
file a countersuit saying he does have
the right to run shows you we are not
talking about elections anymore power is
not being won in the seat of government
by people saying I hereby choose this
man to represent me it's being won by
powerful special interests who are
funneling money into Super Pacs who can
go after prominent media who can go
after politicians and Destroy them
through procedure and process instead of
the actual electoral process when that
happens and it's happening now we do not
have a constitutional republic of duly
elected reps who are bringing our
interest to DC we have powerful monied
tribal interests
asserting what they can and can't do and
it starts with them breaking into the
office of a republican dressed as
construction workers it starts with a
January 6th committee filing subpoenas
against members of the media whether you
like them or not costing them at minimum
a hundred thousand dollars to to comply
with this garbage it is beyond insane
now now I'm I'm just gonna I'm gonna
keep this rant going in 2018 I said the
street violence was going to escalate
into Civil War and people who are who
are too short-sighted said how could
that ever possibly happen you're wrong
Tim it won't happen and I said when the
culture War reaches the highest levels
of government it doesn't matter what you
think the United States is capable of
doing when one military branch opposes
the other when one political party is at
odds of the other and they view each
other as fundamentally criminal evil
Liars that's how it starts that's how
Civil War happens we are literally at
the point where the January 6 committee
is filing subpoenas and in trying to
imprison members of the previous
administration
come 2022 if the Republicans win do you
think Democrats are going to be like a
good game everybody we see the American
people uh have agreed that you're the
right leadership for this country and of
course not absolutely you think they
won't give up their office
no I think they have no idea dude look
at what they're doing with the uh with
January 6 committee
Alex Jones is on video saying do not go
in the capital what did they do they
subpoena him costing him a hundred
thousand dollars they have powerful
money to interests launching lawsuits
against them and trying to destroy
everything about them look at Joe Rogan
it was a Democrat political action
committee that was pushing this video to
force Rogan to apologize and to try and
take his show down these are powerful
political interests and they are using
every procedural law fair tactic they
can to cause problems it's escalated
Beyond just political action and culture
War issues when Democrats used the power
of law enforcement to go after regular
Americans like that woman in Alaska who
had nothing to do with January 6 she was
at a rally for them to start claiming
anyone who supported the president at a
rally unrelated to the capital Riot is
now an insurrectionist who can't hold
office
the the gates of Civil War have been
opened okay now the states are are are
uh we're seeing geographical
polarization based on vaccine policy and
restriction we're seeing people flee
blue states to Red States like like
Texas and Florida geographical
polarization is happening ideological
polarization has already solidified the
next thing we're going to see in that
worries me is if they start
disqualifying people like Marjorie
Taylor green Lauren bobert Madison
cawthorne which they are literally
trying to do right now
what do you think the Maga movement of
75 million people is going to say when
they're like sorry the candidates you
you elected are no longer allowed to go
to Congress yo people are going to lose
it it's like basically being told by one
side you do not get representation in
this country well if you deny the
American people representation and say
they're no longer a part of the system
why would they view you as part of their
system either and then you'll start
getting stuff like what happened with
the bundies you'll get right-wing groups
saying if our rep isn't being is it like
you know Lauren bulb or Colorado if they
don't allow her to run or they
disqualifier they're going to be like
well if you don't recognize us you are
not legitimate we're we're blocking
these roads we're taking over it's it's
one step at a time no no taxation
without representation yeah I mean
ultimately I I would predict that those
lawsuits would fail thankfully because I
I mean I don't know how dramatic I mean
I could see it being a really really bad
situation kind of like what you're
articulating if you know they've managed
to exclude like 10 or so Republican
Congress
I agree with you I think it is likely to
fail it's an insane Prospect I will say
first it can happen here opt to get the
optimism and normalcy bias out of there
everyone has always said this the people
who stayed behind in World War II
Germany who are like ah it's not going
to happen and then it did but the other
thing I'll say is
one side is going to lose this fight the
left or the right do you think either
side will accept defeat do you think if
these left-wing Democratic establishment
people who say Madison cawthorne is an
insurrectionist do you think they're
going to sit back and be like well he's
in Congress now he's the one passing the
abortion ban bill after Roe v Wade gets
overturned by the Supreme Court they're
going to be like he's illegitimate he
was sued and it was a republican judge
or whatever yeah so I think to piggyback
off of points that both of you made
earlier uh you were you were saying that
you think this is going to end with one
side dominating the other you were
saying that you think it's basically
going to break out into Civil War
I would argue and maybe this is a little
too pessimistic but
at some point it's just inevitable that
there's going to be some level of
violence because even if it doesn't
break out into a full-on Civil War what
you're sort of talking about with one
side lording over the other is basically
as Orwell put it just a boot stomping a
face so you just end up having violence
from the State against ordinary people
who are just trying to live their lives
peacefully people get pulled in yeah let
me show you this article we got this is
a conversation that occurred between rep
Adam kinzinger who hates Trump and hates
the Maga movement to Wolf Blitzer he
said that there was a very real
possibility of Civil War I'll just jump
down to the part we get into the quote
he said I never would say that we would
ever have ended up in that position but
now I believe it's a real possibility
that we have to be wide-eyed as we walk
into it so we don't have that happen
again he appeared to mock their health
blah blah talking about Trump
Wolf Blitzer said you it was it was it
was like you're you're seriously saying
you fear a Civil War as possible and he
said a year ago I would have said no not
a chance but I have come to realize that
when we don't see each other as fellow
Americans when we begin to separate into
cultural identities when we begin to
basically give up everything that we
believe so we can be part of a group and
then when you have leaders that come and
abuse that Faith faithfulness of that
group to Violent ends as we saw in
January 6 we would be naive to think it
is not possible here in my earlier
segment I said he was wrong about the
last part I want to revise last part I'm
going to revise it Adam kinzinger's
quote here is one of the most correct
statements ever made I've ever read in
politics
I'll tell you why he's correct yeah
people are tribalizing but he goes on to
say when that faithfulness of that group
uh when you have leaders that come and
abuse the faithfulness of that group to
Violent ends as we saw in January 6 we
would be naive to think it's not
possible here now first I was saying
he's wrong about that because that
manipulation is is it's not driven by
it's it's an exaggeration the conflict
we're seeing I'm gonna revise that
what we're seeing is on January 6th a
bunch of Democrats and a bunch of
uniparty politicians like kinzinger
weaponized a ride at the Capitol to use
the power of law enforcement to crush
their political Rivals and disqualify
them from holding office he's correct
they are abusing the faithfulness of
their in-group to wield the power of
government against their political
opponents he's wrecked when people start
viewing each other as
the good guys versus the fascists or
whatever there's nothing you can do
about well I don't like the Left Right
Paradigm because I don't think of the
leftist villains I don't want to think
ever think of other people's villains in
this game it will die if that if we play
sometimes people are villains well some
people everyone can be villainous but
that doesn't mean that people are
villains well I mean yeah good and evil
we just read a story about Capitol
police officers dressed as construction
workers breaking into a GOP reps office
I know that there's a global fascist
attempt at a takeover I understand it's
been going on for like a hundred it's
probably going for a thousand two
thousand years since the Roman is that
evil what they did it's horrible yeah
it's devastating human soul now now when
the Capitol Police Powers were expanded
by the January 6 committee and there are
those people evil for fascist militants
okay so so here's my issue I'm
specifically referring to the Democrat
you to party politicians who are
manipulating the people to gain power
now what happens in most wars when you
have regular people who don't have
anything to do with the conflict are
pulled up into that conflict and are
sent out as soldiers to go fight and die
the point is the little guy is always
the pawn they're always manipulated by
the powerful Elites right now you have
do nothing neocon Republicans you have
American you know
um pro-america uh anti-establishment
figures of varying political backgrounds
and they say fascist and all right they
would accuse you of being all right and
fascist this would result in people
physically attacking you or this show
getting swatted because people tried to
kill us twice isn't that evil
is it yeah that was a if they knew what
they were doing yeah it's attention so
when he says that you have leaders
abusing the faithfulness of their group
to Violent ends he's right he's right oh
yeah and so what do you do when you have
my let me ask you Ian if if a zombie
horde was coming at you and threatening
you would you be like the zombies don't
know what they're doing they're not evil
no you'd be like I'm sorry I mean the
point of the game is to kill the Zombies
then you kill the Zombies those are
zombies it's a fantasy what I'm saying
is when you have a large political
faction two large political factions and
they inherently they have fundamentally
Different World Views it doesn't matter
who's right or wrong at that point
certainly I think some people are more
right than others and some people are
more guilty than others the issue is
Adam kinzinger says a civil war is is is
is very possible and you'd be naive to
think otherwise the fact is you have
Troy Nell saying this did happen to me I
truly believe if Civil War is possible
and if you think otherwise you're
deluding yourself it's completely
possible right now we have to be careful
that it doesn't happen but here's my
point make you in you say you don't want
to you know in group out group or left
and right that doesn't matter these
people already hate you and they will
never like you most people don't hate me
that yo I mean I don't really know when
everybody says like hey Ian I hate you
yes
I don't care about texts on the internet
that dude so Ian you are you're you're
correct that in your everyday life most
people you encounter who aren't
chronically online aren't going to have
any kind of issue with you however they
have already drawn battle lines and they
don't see you as a human being they see
you as representative of everything evil
in the world because you oppose their
ideology so it doesn't matter if you put
them in the category of evil they view
you as evil and they will do everything
they possibly can to eliminate your
rights you may be right but we're you're
making assumptions let me let me ask you
something I don't think so would you uh
you're in a museum and there's the
constitution in that glass
and you're standing in front of it and
then all of a sudden a bunch of people
come in and they say get out of the way
Ian we're going to burn that burn that
Constitution would you would you say
he'll probably step aside yeah everybody
have weapons and Pitchfork yeah I'm not
giving my life for a piece of paper I
know what the Constitution says I have
pictures of it well a lot of people in
this country would be like I will not
step aside well that's then they're
they're worshiping an idol and they
should stop doing that it's not worship
again it's a piece of paper who cares we
have the document we don't need the
paper so so this is kind of my point
there are a lot of people in this
country who would be like this founding
document created the greatest nation on
the planet preserved civil rights
granted civil rights made one of the
greatest economies and and the American
dream I will sacrifice myself to make
sure that other people have that same
opportunity that I will do but I'm not
good enough for a piece of paper for the
idea
I mean whether you would agree to
sacrifice yourself or not I think saying
it's just a piece of paper is really
reductionist it's so much more than the
sum of its parts as I would say and also
it really represents something so for
example if you have like a signed
photographer or you have a you know a
family heirloom from a loved one who has
passed away it takes on a meaning beyond
the literal object itself and that's of
course true of the Constitution as well
that's idolization I don't think so no
you can recognize the context of
something and see its value based on
that without Idols
I would smash these to bits dude I don't
care sure
um but I I think that one of the
problems with with idolizing an idol
worship at its root is that you're
putting something in a category where it
doesn't belong and I don't think the
Constitution merely belongs in the
category of piece of paper it's it's
obviously a lot more than that I kind of
see like burning a flag like it's just a
symbol the data is important we need to
preserve the data but the con the
Constitution itself is more like a
document so uh you're standing in front
of the uh amalgam of U.S history the
last remaining copies of all of them for
it man if I if this is my life to
preserve the state yeah so this is this
is probably a better way to uh to
explain it the left wants year zero
right Pol Pot he wanted to purge all the
all you know culture uh Mao Great Leap
Forward all that stuff cultural
revolution they wanted to purge the all
the traditional stuff this is indicative
of Communists as opposed to the fascists
who are very traditionalist so you have
a faction in this country that is lying
about history 1619 project is fabricated
it makes no sense they say this country
was was created as a slaveocracy that's
an overt lie it's an outright lie it's
just not true and they say the purpose
of this country was that white people
could have slaves is literally not true
it's not true so you have actual history
and there's probably a lot of problems
with history let's be real because it's
written by a you know it's written by
The Victors his story but let's but but
you but you would you would die to
preserve the truth
Yeah man they would kill to destroy the
tree I know so what do you do when you
are tasked with preserving the truth and
they are tasked with destroying it I'd
be as subtle as I can until the very
moment and then they're like okay now
it's your chance and to have the power
and then when they're like now give me
the power back Ian I give them the power
back it's the Unstoppable force and the
immovable object so this is how War
happens it doesn't matter if you think
they're evil or not what what matters is
there are a lot of regular people who
don't pay attention who only watch CNN
who have no idea what you know and when
they see the truckers they're told
they're fascist far right white
supremacists and they say okay and then
they go and vote for politicians who
weaponize law enforcement to crush
political opponents and then you have
whatever this weird group of people we
are which is you know post-liberal
libertarian conservative and we're like
the truth is what matters most I think
about it almost every day I mean how do
you navigate in a system where it's
basically built with people that will
kill sociopaths that will kill to
preserve power and snub out that version
of History they don't want to be told
but to be an honest truth teller like
how do you do that in this world you got
to make people laugh you got to make
sure everybody has fun while you're
doing it and maybe you can make the
villainous authoritarians realize hey
it's life's pretty cool and it's okay if
it's not the way you want it to be
beating him in elections a few times in
a row would help I don't know yeah
political parties do change the result
for that like my long-term thesis about
like what is what does Victory look like
in the medium term is something like
what the conservatives in England did to
the labor party in the 80s when Margaret
Thatcher just beat labor badly like
three times in a row
um and labor went from being like a
pretty hardcore socialist movement to
like the neoliberal Tony Blair party
because they wanted to win
um and so I think you know the world
where a world where like Republicans win
like three or four elections in a row
convincingly and and I think that's
quite possible in a world where the left
keeps doing the stuff they've they've
absolutely the left is found itself I
mean they're they're moving towards
censorship they're moving towards this
stuff because they're losing traction I
mean we the generic ballot poll was
something like for the first time it's
like plus four were for Republicans it
hasn't been Plus for republicans in two
decades or something and Gallup found a
party affiliation for the first time in
like 30 years is now pro-republican
right so if so so this is is all very
doomsday to be homely honest however
if in November Republicans get a
commanding sweep and then immediately
put a stop to what the Democrats are
doing and shut it all down
then I would actually say I think you
know things are set like the the the
temperature is lowering the the the the
boil is reducing and then
um it depends on how Democrats respond
to it because you still have the
executive branch you still have Joe
Biden then we'll see what happens when
Donald Trump he's running he's it's no
question about it he's effectively said
he's running and all of his you know
former staff well many of us former
staff have publicly stated he's running
even to us then when he runs we'll see
what happens because you look at what
happened on January uh 20th 2017 with
the riding in DC the Insurrection you
take a look at what happened in uh when
was it when the far left was trying to
jump the the fence the White House and
set fire they literally broke the
barrier of the White House and the
summer of 2020 and they set fire to a
guard post they they set fire to a
church 50 uh agents were injured it was
2020. wow yes that was in 20 years so so
what do you think happens if we get
if we get in November a republican sweep
of Congress and then they start passing
bills and laws the left who's already
completely insane are going to reignite
the whole BLM wave of writing all that
all that insanity is going to be right
there this is the burning of the Saint
John's Church is what you guys and
that's a DC it's June 2nd 2020. so what
happens then in uh 2024 when it's like
September and Donald Trump is winning in
all the polls
do you think they'll learn their lesson
and NFL will come out and be alike we're
so sorry we did this to you guys please
don't vote for them or do you think
they're going to be like fascist of one
it's time to revolt well yeah so first
of all obviously I know you're you're
being a little facetious there but they
will never apologize for anything
they'll just move on to the next Racket
and they'll start pointing the finger at
Republicans look at all these horrible
things they've done look at the human
rights abuses Trump wants to implement I
think people are going to be smarter
than to look where the people who were
burning the country down are pointing I
can't imagine that people would support
another year of rioting and burning
buildings yeah well and also I don't so
we we've we've discussed this before and
we've we've um compared the way the left
behaves to a child throwing a temper
tantrum and it really can go in one of
two directions when they keep throwing
the Tantrum and it doesn't work they can
either double down and keep doing it or
they can grow up and learn how to behave
productively I'm not sure which
direction they're going to take it's
it's going to be very dependent on the
particular left wing
to ship culture like what I think one of
the you know one good thing that would
come out of a law that sort of banned
social media censorship and
de-platforming is it would just take the
teeth out of all this dumb activism that
seems to juice the most authoritarian
impulses the Left Right social media
yeah you know like yes if they if if you
could just get them like if this Joe
Rogan stuff would be like Spotify would
put out instead of that simping like
ridiculous statement that the Spotify
CEO put out about how sorry he was if he
just put out a statement that was like
federal law prohibits us from doing
anything like what you guys suggest so
Joe Rogan staying on the platform uh you
know take a hike and if that were I mean
you know take that across like YouTube
Twitter whatever if all those companies
just realized if we do what the leftists
want we'll be in violation of federal
law and yeah yeah you know like so that
would I mean it would do a lot to
decrease the temperature well and I
agree with you I think that that would
decrease the temperature a lot one thing
I said on the show the other day is that
I've known a lot of left-wing people and
I've seen how they behave in groups and
I've also seen how they're willing to
behave one-on-one with me when they they
have conversations and they are far more
left-leaning when they are around other
left-wing people what I like to say is
you're honestly not a leftist until
there's two of you when you're alone
having a conversation with someone who
has a different political perspective
than you you're much more open willing
to hear but as soon as they get around
someone who is left leaning they feel
the need to signal that they're the more
left-leaning person that starts with
someone with a weak mind that just
adapts to whoever they're around that's
that's what it is yeah I want to explain
why I think a Republican election is
more likely to result in violence and
escalation than de-escalation and you
were mentioning beating them a few times
in a row might be good but you take a
look at the punch a Nazi thing that
happened when the left engages in
violence the media celebrates and cheers
for it when the left tore down the
security barrier at the White House and
then set fire to a guard post in a
church and Trump was forced into a
bunker they made fun of him mocked him
and called him bunker boy and cheered
for it when BLM burnt down uh causing
buildings causing two billion dollars in
Insurance damage and that's the minimum
that's that that's the max payout so
that's not even I should say of them
that's not even all the damages and they
said your insurance will cover it when
David Dorn was shot in the chest and
killed over a TV they didn't talk about
it they didn't care when they commit
acts of violence it's it's powerful
resistance against evil and fascism
so if if Republicans end up winning it
justifies everything they've said maybe
but I mean it depends if we get a little
bit more of a competent Administration I
don't know that we will because I mean
I'm not you know impressed I mean
Trump's big weakness is his ability to
make the rest of the executive branch do
what he wants or do you know he's just
not good at it right he's not good at
influencing but I don't know you get a
scientist type in there I don't I don't
I just I don't it's just what what
happens in a world where like doj
actually meaningfully enforces the law
and starts imposing serious penalties on
these people like I mean there's there
the reason this stuff happens in my
judgment a big chunk of it it's not
substantially deterred like they're just
not prosecuted
um and I think you you start that's
that's my point like you like you saw
Jason Charter right that kid who like
punched you remember that time of the
Jack got punched or you know pushed
around at that Lincoln Rally or whatever
that kid got like
three months probation
and that after he also destroyed some
monuments right he was like charged to
destroying monuments a felony that got
pled down to misdemeanor and he only got
three months per day so if Trump ends up
getting elected in 2024 and we make it
through the next several years without
substantial violence and escalation and
then he purges the executive branch in
the Department of Justice to replace all
these prosecutors and these Federal
prosecutors across the country who
didn't prosecute any of this maybe then
we'd see some meaningful change but that
is taught that you what you're basically
saying is he needs to purge the entirety
of the other political faction I don't
know that he needs to purge the entirety
of the other political faction out of
doj but he definitely needs to like
Purge the top ranks needs to like and
there needs to be much more I mean
another big problem is that doj was just
swallowed up in an endless Scandal right
like we mean the Mueller report and the
Russia nonsense like most of Trump's
first term was just you know swallowed
by Distraction rather than governance
when the Democrats are in power when the
left the progressive left in the
establishment of power they use it to
justify a mandate from the people to do
all these things when they're out of
power they they claim the fascists are
winning and use it to justify their acts
of violence and revolt against the
system until they get power back
so I just I look at everything that's
been happening and I there's that you
know quote I think I can't remember I
keep forgetting the guy's name where he
says when I am weak I ask you for
freedom because it's according to your
principles when I'm strong I deny you
freedom because it's according to mine
that's from Dune that's uh Frank Herbert
Frank Herbert the author of dude yeah so
if the Republicans win in November
certainly I think they'll start taking
action and trying to pass bills Biden
will probably veto a good majority of
them and the left will argue see we were
right the whole time we need antifa and
we need to engage in direct action
they'll call it to stop the fascists so
I want to acknowledge like what I think
is happening cultural revolution Mao uh
you talk about a culture War I think
that what happened is this communist
mentality bled into our country sometime
20 30 years ago maybe through social
media and now a generation of children
have been raised with that mindset or or
a sect of that generation so that's
reality how do we deal with that
peacefully
um I mean serious curriculum changes uh
it would be one place to do it right
like teaching the horrors of Communism
yeah as like a mandatory thing and I
mean I think that would have to be done
by States right because it's probably
not like a federal initiative to do that
but like that's what I mean you're
talking about like peaceful change uh oh
radical shift of University I mean you
know co-optation or destruction of the
existing University system that would be
by the state governments uh that I don't
know if a federal or state right you
could massively can make the loans
contingent on certain changes uh adding
political affiliation one simple one I I
thought of is like making political
affiliation a protected class uh for
universities and then forcing them to
hire X number of conservatives everybody
but that's that's really tough because
what political affiliations are you
willing to then tolerate Nazi really
really tricky but you know you I mean I
think like you end up kind of getting to
a place where if you have the the will
to impose that kind of legislation on
them you can kind of negotiate and get
what you need which is like serious
large chunks of University staff being
conservative but what is it what how do
you how do you how does how does a
university mandate someone being
conservative and what is conservative
and how do you know I don't know that I
mean they they added in they've managed
to do that with every other aspect of
diversity like I'm sure they could we
could figure something out I don't think
they have actually
well I mean you know like the gender uh
gender identity sexual preference but
that but but a lot of that is fairly
nebulous which is resulting in you know
political conflict and crisis it might
be nebulous but it's still I mean even
if it's vague it doesn't mean that it's
like completely ambiguous and un you
know unachievable like there's some
reason the campuses have gotten so much
diverse in like why you know if you're a
white male looking for a professorial
position you're really SOL at a lot of
universities a Nazi shows up to
University and says they're conservative
and want a job and they say no you're a
Nazi and he says no I'm not I'm a
conservative and then files a suit
what's a judge going to do
it's hard to it's it would be hard to
exclude like the the edge cases but I
mean maybe you drop legislation that
exclude figures that you figure out a
way to do it or not but I mean maybe
this is undoable in which case we just
need to cut off all funding to the
universities and start our own
institutions and essentially force a
preference for those new institutions I
think universities need to be purged but
we have a cultural problem and uh it's
amazing you know I was watching Star
track the Next Generation and I was like
Boomers did this yes and they did a
really great job but why did they screw
up everything else the universities for
instance man yeah you know it's just
it's it's um
polarization and I don't mean political
I mean in general you had people in the
70s who went to the universities with a
specific goal and they created a very
narrow band of what they were going to
do some people went into popular media
and it was all very narrow
universities I think are a huge mistake
uh the left worships them they're
they're cult you know it just goes to
show you that these are basically uh
cult community centers I saw this post
on Reddit where the left was making fun
of the right someone on the Right Said
universities are where most bad ideas
are born it's like prageru and then all
the comments were like laughing how much
smarter they were than them and how
universities are where smart people go
and things like that and I'm like it
just goes to show you that these people
live in a world where the the majority
of good ideas and education comes from
the institutionalized learning facility
where you become you know you get your
you get turned into a box whereas I
think whatever our faction is recognizes
that people come from all different
backgrounds of all different experiences
and you can become educated and learn it
through many different ways maybe you
just maybe you just uh refused to
subsidize anything that's not stem right
that would be more interesting way of
like essentially basically saying that
you know universities like no money that
from the federal government can go
towards FX studies programs what about
the Arts sorry not in college you could
do it elsewhere right and the federal
government doesn't need to subsidize it
through the university system maybe they
you could set up your own independent
like art scholar I think one of the one
of the funny one of the funniest posts I
saw from a leftist was on uh it was on
one of those like anti-work subreddits
and it was a guy on Twitter saying I
think that if a plumber wants to learn
about you know Russian history they
should be able to go to university free
of charge and learn all about it and
then they can keep working their job but
still have access to knowledge knowledge
should be free and I'm just like take a
YouTube class yeah but someone has to
pay for that someone has to do the work
the building has to exist these people
you know look man you also you can
actually just go online they're trying
to solve a problem that already has a
very clear and much more straight and
they were trying to stop that like
Phoenix University in the early days
they had a lot of like roadblocks it was
very very threatening in that industry
they were like people can't learn online
and then in 2020 they're like everyone
has to take online courses all right why
do we need undergraduate Humanities
departments actually like now that I
think about it like do we do we need
them as country are they are they net
beneficial for the country first of all
yeah I remember Humanity's being like a
fun class with a nice teacher I don't
remember what we did or anything funny
story when you just said churches uh you
know what the most dominant major at the
turn of the 20th century was
theology wow um and it used to be that
that's what like most people and I
realized that like you know there's
always been a huge demand for you know
midwits to be able to like take go to
school to learn to point out blasphemy
right that's what they did at the turn
of the 20th century in theology class
and that's what they're doing now in
these X Studies classes so I I totally
disagree at the turn of the 20th century
you actually had to be pretty
intelligent in order to get into any
kind of University setting yeah yeah so
the way I describe it to people this is
my personal hypotheses on our cultural
developments over the past several
decades
I was I was told over and over again in
school by my family that the children of
the greatest Generation they uh they
they these are the greatest Generation
had high school education and were able
to raise a family of five just that
alone
they had a bunch of kids these are the
Boomers
the Boomers grow up and what do they see
their peers brothers sisters friends and
and otherwise who went to college made
more money than they did yeah and so
they instill in their Millennial
children you have to go to college look
I didn't go and everybody my friend went
and he's making six figures and I never
made that much so you need to go to
college and here's what I realized
if if if the greatest generation was
able to raise a family of five off just
a high school diploma they did not tell
their Boomer children to go to college
you didn't need to you could raise your
family in a high school diploma what
this means is the Boomer those in the
boomer generation who went to college
did so to pursue a passion they were
driven and they chose I want to go here
and do this thing
unsurprisingly people who are passionate
and driven to search and explore became
good at these tasks were driven to
succeed and ultimately made more money
now what we have is Boomer parents told
their kids you have to go to college
that's the path towards towards money
and it never was now we have on a
massively indebted generation of
Communists who think the solution is the
government bailing them out because they
never should have gone in the first
place and passion was always the key so
now you have all of you you have this
this is my favorite stat
College Dropout billionaires have on
average three times more money than PhD
billionaires you have all of these
stories of high school dropout
Millionaires and celebrities and
entrepreneurs all the time I mean some
of the most revered entrepreneurs Steve
Jobs College shop I think Bill Gates was
a College Dropout as well these are
people who pursued a passion and said
College isn't what I need Peter Thiel I
think I don't know if he still does he
had the uncollege movement trying to
instill this message in people yeah but
now you have Millennials all believing
it's not passion it's not drive it's not
inquisitiveness it's just getting your
degree this is from no wonder there's no
interest one in eight billionaires drop
out of college here's a fun one I just
realized like another thing you could
really do to break the power of colleges
uh you ban Federal discrimination on
academic basically academic credentials
right essentially like what that means
is you're not allowed to like ask people
on their resume and you're not allowed
to put what your race is well now you
couldn't put your degrees
literally but actually your other
experience but I wouldn't have went to
college if that's the case
exactly I agree but I think there's a
better way to put it yeah
it's that you only can ask about the
qualifications for regulated positions
meaning a doctor a lawyer or a CPA or
things like that right so the law
wouldn't be like you're not allowed to
ask the law would be you are only
allowed to ask if we've regulated this
position here the list of jobs that have
to be regulated by degree and you can
let people voluntarily put it on their
resume if they want to they could Supply
information but I think you probably
have to prohibit it I think you probably
just have to be like you know this is
basically put the company in position
where they're like if they see the
resume and it has a college you know the
way they would if they saw like the rate
you know race or something like that
they'd be like we're not even touching
this because we don't want to be in the
position of discriminating and and what
you do is you simply say this show me
your portfolio yes what's the job you're
being hired for yes so you know what's
really funny when you hire a contractor
how do you know they can do it
you look at the reviews on Angie's List
or whatever so why am I going to assume
some guys got a degree they're going to
know how to do whatever it is they're
talking about no it's all the same it's
all guesswork well a lot of people end
up working in a field very differently
than the one they majored in and part of
the reason for that is the value that
employers tend to find in a degree is it
shows you that the person was capable of
sticking with something for an extended
period of time in order to meet their
goal that's true and I feel like I have
to Circle back real quick to what Tim
was talking about earlier he was talking
about how Boomers looked at the people
who went to college or if the people
previous to Boomers looked at the people
who went to college and said they
succeeded therefore you should go I feel
like this is one of the Cornerstone
tripping Stones that's happened to
Millennials I feel like this is one of
those reversal of cause and effect that
they looked at and they said this
therefore this instead of looking at it
the other way and I see a lot of people
just as we're doing this segment on
Generations people are saying I skipped
Gen X no I didn't Generations hop so you
have the silent generation and then I
think the silent generation made the had
the Gen X right yeah greatest head
Boomers Boomers had Millennials gen xers
had gen Z there's a there's LeapFrogs
yeah yeah so uh the issue gen X's I
think were pretty rad for the most part
but they're just politically weak and
they have no idea what's going on they
didn't have on the internet they were
raised without it another thing I want
to mention that I think is hilarious
about people who went to college sort of
arrogantly declaring that makes them
more intelligent than anyone else is in
order to do that you have to just
completely uncritically accept the most
Baseline way of defining intelligence
can you memorize stuff exactly what well
and also you're just assuming that
degree equals intelligence that's such
an absurd idea right because you can be
a stupid person that repeats information
and have no idea how to put those ideas
together to form a new idea well and
we've been we have been consistently
dumbing higher education down for about
150 years now maybe maybe closer to 100
years
sure yes I feel very very strongly about
this because this is a classic case of
them looking at something like for
example self-esteem and saying that kids
who had high self-esteem did well in
school that is exactly backwards kids
who did well in school earned their High
self-esteem the people who went to
college because they were passionate
about something did well in that field
and whether they dropped out or not the
fact that they went and they decided to
pursue a degree or career and came out
ahead of the curve was an exact
inversion of the reason we're pushing
everyone to go to college we're telling
telling everyone that they must have
high self-esteem in order to succeed
these are exactly backwards and I think
this is part of the reason that
Millennials are so turned around it is
exactly an inversion of the truth I
think
well let's go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
honk the like button and subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends if you really do like it because
that really helps and go to timcast.com
become a member because we are primarily
supported by memberships that's how we
keep keep the lights on employ all our
journalists and pay for all the
infrastructure with your support we will
expand we will do more of this we will
launch new shows and we will combat the
fake news media we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up for all
of our members at timcast.com around 11
or so PM so you don't want to miss it
make sure you sign up again and let's
read your super chats we got this from
rylo he says honk honk let's go Brando
Tim I appreciate you doing this and
putting yourself out there what you do
means truckloads to lots of people I
love it I really I I appreciate that red
Viking says I trust Tim Poole regards
from Denmark I really appreciate that
and I'm I'm I'm humbled and grateful
all right Cowboy Shane says I've already
obtained permission from my company
which is one of the largest national
carriers in America to dress my company
truck in the All-America in all the
American Freedom Convoy Gucci gear I
have no idea what that is but it sounds
very interesting sounds good
all right Zeke schwenky says Tim how can
you be both pro-choice and anti-death
penalty only one of those always result
in an innocent death love your work just
been wanting to ask you this for a while
it is a greatly complicated question and
it's uh actually relatively simple the
issue of abortion is a language issue
when I'm talking about Choice I'm not
talking about women literally just
deciding to abort a completely healthy
and viable baby for literally no reason
I think that's wrong however I think
there's a governmental there's a problem
I have with the idea that you have a
woman let's say she has a health issue I
don't like the idea that the government
intervenes and says tell us about those
health issues before you get approval
for a procedure from your doctor the
same way I feel about vaccine mandates
the issue is if you know you have a
private medical decision that's between
you and your like you should be you
should be forced to go around and tell
people this admittedly it's an extremely
difficult position to to to uh it's an
extremely difficult moral position
because it's it's involving two
different lives and the rights of two
individuals who are who are joined and I
don't think I have the answers for how
you solve legal questions and the rights
of individuals when they're two people
in one body that's inherently difficult
as for the death penalty it's an
entirely different circumstance ah if
Kamala Harris walked up to you and said
if this guy over here should die trust
me I'd be like no you're an evil person
there's literally no one in government
who can come to me and say just trust me
we should kill that guy I'd be like no
if you've subdued the person they're
locked in a box I don't trust you I just
don't do it if I witnessed a criminal
committing an extremely egregious act
against somebody I would act in defense
of others using Force necessary to stop
them from doing it and that could result
in a loss of life
it's unfortunate I don't want people to
die but they're not the same things and
I think they're totally different
arguments I I disagree I I mean
I would say the only way in which
they're different is that every time
someone dies as a result of abortion
we're guaranteed that they were innocent
my question to you because you're sort
of bringing up the complexity here so I
guess my question to you would be
what was wrong with the laws that
existed prior to Roe v Wade when
abortion actually was illegal entirely
in some states what law specifically I
know that the country was capable of
having abortion laws which entirely
prohibited it because that was the case
prior to really wait in many states and
so I think they're arguing in by a
language a language discussion you're
talking about something different right
so we've had this conversation before
where your view of abortion is the
arbitrary killing of an unborn baby yeah
I'm not talking about that so you would
you you believe that should be illegal
the the I I don't know about the problem
I have with drawing a line at making uh
I think it's wrong and I think people
shouldn't do it but the question about
illegality is government intervention to
monitor this to make sure it wasn't or
was is the difficult position so you're
saying like an investigation after the
fact or before but like like how would
this work like a woman let's say she's
got like
um cysts or something and the doctor
says you're both gonna die we need to
act quick she'll be back well let me
file my requisition forms the government
make sure we can get a proper approval
on this before we move forward with this
procedure the issue is that I recognize
life thing as a conception anyone who
says otherwise is lying for political
reasons and they have no argument yeah
vosh was asked about this on the show
and he said he was asked by Charlie Kirk
when does Life Begin he goes I don't
know birth yeah or what did he say like
six months or something I'm just like
dude come on man there's there's no
argument there yeah but there is a
challenging discussion around I'm not uh
the left uses pro-choice often it it
used to mean safe legal and rare and it
used to reference specifically the
health of the mother and whether or not
you know women have the right to go to a
doctor and make the decision amongst
themselves that government intervention
pro-choice today means pro-abortion so
I'm I'm actually opposed to abortion I
think it's wrong but
we shouldn't conflate abortion which is
which you know the the term meaning
women saying I want to kill this baby
with the doctor saying we think there's
a very strong possibility that you will
die the baby will die and the also the
the alternative and that's something
I've said for a while I don't know if I
can tolerate the government saying You
must up uh you you're obligated to
provide your body to another person yeah
sure so um I would say that when it
comes to medically necessitated abortion
I mean you have you have the the Dublin
declaration and also you don't even
necessarily need the Dublin declaration
there's a lot of doctors who will tell
you this that actually going in and
Performing uh an abortion is never a
medical necessity sometimes there are
instances where you might need to
perform an operation on a woman who is
pregnant that can result in the death of
the unborn child but those are not
abortions because your goal is not to
kill the child your goal is to perform a
different operation that could result in
the child being hurt so that is
different from an abortion and the law
would factor that in I think they're
involuntary abortions at that Point well
I want we got to read more miscarriage
yeah yes but uh
I think we'll end up talking back and
forth you know what I mean so but uh
yeah it could be a good discussion on an
after show or another time yeah
definitely absolutely let's read some
more we got Dustin Jones says hey Tim
did you see the Daily Mail article
titled Biden admin to fund programs that
hand out cracked pipes to promote racial
Equity yes that's a freebies originally
and uh I was browsing Reddit as I often
do and there was a leftist subreddit
mocking Charlie Kirk because Charlie
Kirk said something like the bite
Administration is going to be giving out
free crack pipes but they can't deal
with you know this that or otherwise
these other problems and the response
from the left was he's lost his mind
what is he even talking about and I'm
just like these people are so stupid
they think they're smarter than Charlie
and Charlie said stupid things like
nobody's perfect but he's talking about
a legitimate news story they just don't
read the news they just sit there
twiddling their thumbs laughing about
how smart they are
yikes man well they went to college Tim
yeah they sure did by the way sure
they're so smart that means they're
smart
yeah yeah exactly
from some overpriced like private
exactly in the middle of nowhere like
you went hundreds of thousands of
dollars into debt or tens of thousands
of dollars into debt because your
parents told you to and you're the smart
one I think okay that's right Orville
redenpillar says anti-truck
discrimination you can't say trucker
that's our word
it's not okay to say trucker in any
context good to know it's a verb wait no
it's not Brandon Tom says Tim regarding
your 4 pm video how do you feel about
the government interfering in hostage
situations you mention them a lot aren't
hostage takers entitled to privacy from
the government like pregnant women I
don't know if that makes any sense an
analogy is insane
like that's just no no there's there's
obviously a the question is you know the
the prior question is is there like a
wrong a criminal wrong being committed
right like and so like if you there's
obviously a criminal wrong being
committed in the world of a hostage
taking that's kidnapping right and that
there is a fundamental debate in the
abortion debate about whether that is
like a crime or should be a crime like
that's that's the difference between
those two things like yeah that's not
the result well I I think he's asking
more I think he's asking more
philosophically than legally though
because in some sense and I agree like
this is there's a huge problem here when
you discuss abortion which is everyone
sort of brings up analogies and I don't
think any of the analogies work very
well like a mother child relationship is
a very specific thing uh some people
will describe it as you sort of have a
built-in hostage situation I've heard
that verbiage before I certainly don't
prefer it but I think what he's getting
at is the philosophy of the fact that
even in situations where one person does
have full control over another there's
life we're still willingly willing to
say the government should step in the
knowledge I think that's more or less
what they're trying to communicate so I
don't want to go too long because I do
want to read more but let's let's make a
couple points or let me ask uh how do
you feel about the exceptions for rape
and incest and abortion no I don't
believe that there are any exceptions I
believe that the value of a human life
is not contingent on how they were
conceived I completely agree and that's
one that's one that always confused me
about conservatives who are like okay we
agree on however the issue of rape is is
important because I understand the
argument that a woman gets pregnant you
know in most cases made the conscious
decision to engage in human reproductive
acts which result in a pregnancy and
they now have to assume responsibility
for carrying a life that's just how
biology works but then you come into the
question of a woman who is forced into
caring another life and that's where I
think the government doesn't have a
right to say no no no now you are
obligated to provide your blood and body
to another person because someone forced
you force it upon you yeah you really
like violate someone's worst
impregnation like what the uyghurs what
they're going through like how would you
not support them being able to abort
those forced impregnations well so I
believe that rape is an unbelievably
horrific crime I also believe that
abortion is an unbelievably horrific
crime and I don't believe it simply
harms unborn children I really believe
it harms the women as well so I would
say that a woman has undergone something
traumatic and horrible the solution to
that is not to put her through something
else that is also traumatic and horrible
and kill the child well I I think your
morality is irrelevant to the individual
who's making the choice on what their
body is to be used well but then I could
say I can use my body to kill anyone in
your your morality is not uh relevant to
what decisions that's that's not
analogies don't work like you said you
can't have someone latching themselves
onto your blood or you can't have
someone hooking them hooking you up you
know to their bloodstream because their
kidneys don't work and then you and then
you being told by the government you
can't unhook them but that's not my
child
but that's not that's not we're talking
about two individuals who have a right
to life Pursuit of Happiness and if a
woman was forced by someone else whose
rights were violated to carry a life she
didn't want to carry that I don't think
the state has a right to come in and say
I don't care what you want to do with
your body you were forced in this
position and now we're going to make
sure you stay in that position I think
that's right there's a basic like
problem with like I I my problem with
this position is that it it treats the
woman as an instrument of the rapist and
forces the god to continue to act and
facilitate that instrument I don't I
don't think it's seeing her as an
instrument of a rapist I think it's
seeing her as a mother and saying that
mothers can't kill their children and if
so people bring up analogies about
different kinds of relationships but
like I said ultimately the mother child
relationship is a very different thing
what if she says I did not choose this
and I don't want it I think there are a
lot of really difficult things people go
through in life that they don't choose
but that doesn't give them the right to
harm other people what if the baby what
if the baby's born and it's got a kidney
defect and it's going to die
I
want to ask a couple questions okay
because otherwise we'll go for 20 years
yes but I think the point has been made
we disagree yeah we disagree let's read
some more
Mystic says Tim please help us uh be
brave and do something about mask
mandates in our kids schools shout out
to our site open letter to what does it
say open letter to Archbishop laurie.com
it's hard to read when there's names you
know and it's all no spaces
Logan Culver says Ian is right and the
mfn FED geez what do you have to say to
that will I guess I didn't win that yeah
it's not so simple I tried so hard and
you failed to convince and the fed's a
fun catchphrase around Paul made popular
but I'm sorry I didn't convince you we
need to um we need to create something
new if we're gonna undo the old thing
don't just tear it down you need to
create something new that's better and
then we can transition please by the way
think hard about the gold standard guys
it really has been tried and found
wanting I think
by the way I've talked about a lot you
know Ron Paul talking about the gold
standard and I often said like it's an
archaic system it doesn't mean it's
perfect
Christopher Chapman says will of the
people changed my life made me cry where
is the line between fighting and evil
power and the continuous cycle of power
corrupting is a reference to my music
video will of the people you should
check it out we're working on the sequel
to it it's a side call not necessarily a
sequel It's called pain and we got Pete
Parada formerly of The Offspring laying
on the drum tracks for us and it sounds
amazing the idea is what do you think of
that do you use violence to take down a
violent regime like what how does that
wheel stop turning how do you stop that
wheel from turning where do you draw the
line with using violence to overturn a
violent regime like what what's that
guy's answer I guess oh I don't I don't
know if it is possible you know I think
technology for one thing uh I don't know
if it is possible like you look at
what's going on right now when you say
you don't want to do the left right
thing and I'm like dude these people
have tried to kill us twice and I know
my some people might say it's a little
hyperbolic but swatting is an attempt to
end your life the second time the
swatting was I I don't want to give away
too many details for security reasons
but the second swatting was in many ways
worse than the first they were different
but in many ways worse and the goal is
to try and get us killed so the second
time it seemed like they were really
trying to get us killed yeah it's like
what do you do when they're trying to
get you killed man yeah you know just be
like well I don't know Abraham Lincoln
was like well if it's gonna happen it's
going to happen you just kept going
about his day and then he had a dream
that he was dead yeah you ever hear that
story where he had a dream it was like
everyone was crying in the white house
he was like what's happened what's
happened in his dream they're like the
president is dead he's like what and
then the next day I think he got shot or
something within a couple days yeah
crazy man that's one way to go about it
the other way is you could hide in a
bunker like Justin Trudeau there's so
many ways to go all right let's read
some more we got Andrew gelling he says
Ian yo dog I heard you like currency so
we put your currency on some currency so
you can spend while you spend oh good
good good great line Mason says in the
dark ages to the late Middle Ages cities
and counties would mint their own coins
and freely trade with those coins which
were based on the purity of the silver
and gold used to make the coin but
that's still a single currency used
internationally if gold and silver is
the standard which is I think the point
you are making right like the euro is a
central a single currency like gold and
silver would be yeah people would start
doping their currency back then in like
silver plating their copper and then
using yeah yeah people would shave the
the edges off of the coins a little bit
more that's why you have ridges at the
ends of coins now so you know that
someone can just shave into it yeah yeah
wow yeah so if you could just shave a
little bit off of the outside of every
single coin right it's made of precious
metal eventually you're gonna have a lot
of money
now we have pieces of paper I think
there's some cloth well another cotton
fabric how is it yeah I think it's
cotton well that's different now like in
Canada it's all plastic money honestly a
lot of it's just digital now yeah like
overwhelming like 99 of it is digital
all right GBP says a lot of the truckers
are from Alberta Kenny is conservative
but I think he's trying to deflate the
Convoy and get them home well yes comply
with their demands and they'll go home
it's that simple it's like we're gonna
get rid of the mandates like all right
we're out you know yeah there you go
that's the benefit of having a discrete
ask what if they get rid of the Mandate
they leave and then they do the Mandate
again come back they just come back but
then they'll be ready for it you know
what I wonder about these political
leaders did they forget that they live
in a society where they have to do
things for other people because this is
what we were constantly told about the
vaccine did they forget that they have
to consider other people's interests
sometimes unbelievable just comply you
guys all right Noob dupe says heavy duty
tow truck driver here Tim you are right
about the logistics everything is
towable with some work but to toe an
unwilling semi it would take 60 to 90
minutes once you are hooked just to make
it move wow
so perfect I love it there is they have
no power
I love seeing truckers just like sitting
there just like regular working dudes
being like you have no power here like
look at me I am the I am the captain
it's literally it's it's literally like
Bugs Bunny messing with a villain
they're just kind of they're doing their
thing and these people are losing their
minds that's amazing dude Regal says or
Regal says Ian is right about Optimus
Prime being in Canada right now his
motto is freedom is the right of all
sentient beings
love it indeed poofy says Optimus Prime
hashtag blood Feud let's go Optimus dude
he's a good time yeah Orson Welles can
you do that he did this voice for the
movie
for the original Transformers movie who
did Orson Welles did Optimus what I'll
double check it but I'm hunting in the
80s yeah
Smedley Butler III says Ian's right a
select group of banking families
secretly meeting with a select group of
senators on Jekyll Island to own and be
the printing machine for the world is
the exact definition of fascism it's not
the exact but it's pretty close looks
like in the first Transformers we've got
Orson Welles Robert stacked Leonard
Nimoy what a star cast that is cubicle
says this has to be the worst Magic the
Gathering Channel I've ever seen you
haven't mentioned kamigawa dropping this
weekend will you and Ian be attending
pre-release are they gonna have quad
lands are they doing I'm just making fun
of the game the power creep's insane
yeah but there's already exceptions
except for anything except lands yeah
yeah Mana Confluence I don't know
whatever we should play Magic yeah you
know will plays oh I used to what colors
I mean I don't know colors like what are
your main combos I mean I haven't played
in 20 years right so he was playing or
is this block yeah so I guess what what
did I play I played like Drago with disc
and like counter space
because I at that point I was in like
fourth grade and like I could only
afford like cheap Stacks did you get
boomerangs in there I think they were
Boomer pretty Unstoppable uh and then
like maybe there was some I forget was
what is the black green deck that was
really popular by then I don't know man
it was black green it was like a weird I
don't know if it wasn't a necro deck it
was oh uh um Erza's I don't know if
there was mixed color decks during Earth
I remember watching the the old like
Nationals and stuff and like the
tournaments and the dude would do like
turn one swamp Dark Ritual pharoxy and
the gator and it was just like it's done
oh the kid it's like yeah
and if he takes a damage I did mostly
like I love how esoteric this is and so
many people are confused right now did
you just really use some magic on it
let's read some more Super chats we got
Seth he says no Tim the Union soldiers
were already in Fort Sumter the
Confederate soldiers surrounded the fort
and someone from the Confederate side
fired I did not say otherwise my point
was the the materials the fort and that
was there was controlled by the union
that said you can't have that it's ours
and the South said get out and go home
which would effectively be giving up a
powerful expensive military resource and
the Union Soldiers said no that the same
thing would happen if there was a
peaceful divorce in this country you
will have you know whichever side
controls DC you'll have Federal forces
and a military base in say Florida and
then Florida will be like time to go
guys and they're going to be like these
nukes belong to us and we're not leaving
them and they're gonna be like yes you
are and there's no other way it could go
down and what about like Area 51 and all
the underground tunnels and stuff that
probably cross state lines for all I
know yeah and what about the underground
cities full of reptilian people yeah
exactly who gets those in the custody
but underneath that yeah I think they
choose they choose well they're kind of
a cool thing to do but they're going to
say that 50 miles below the surface is
not controlled by uh oh just like the
sky yeah well the sky is FAA how far up
how far down does our jurisdiction go
here eight miles yeah yeah right man you
just made the lizard people are gonna be
like you don't have mineral rights
turn your surface rights on so I I've
looked at a lot of land and all the
mineral rights are gone and for obvious
reasons companies will buy mineral
rights but not the property so that if
they ever want to scan for it or look
for something they own it if you ever
strike or find something they own it so
it's really annoying when you're trying
to buy land you got to make sure you're
buying the mineral rights as well which
is wise a company can come onto your
land and start drilling and digging
because they have rights underneath but
the secret is the real reason mineral
lights mineral rights have been bought
up is because the lizard people one
major nobody yeah I'm saying stuff now
yeah that proves it yeah the lizard
people yeah checks out yeah it's proof
it's proof
low standard of proof there yep
he's got a point
Nicholas Graves says I work for a towing
company in Michigan and I tow semi in
metro Detroit I will refuse to tow any
protesters show me your Honkers that's
the other thing too it's just it's
amazing that uh
it's it's amazing how many of the
truckers are just like
we rely on this industry you know we're
friends of these guys we're not going to
interfere with what they're doing that'd
be yeah that's their immune system like
if your veins are doing you can't rip
your veins out of your body it's a very
very effective protest right like in
terms of the ability to sort of force
the other side to really negotiate with
you normally
you know I mean you just don't have to
do that because the protests aren't
aren't that powerful exactly
Christopher Fisher says Ian is the
Taliban evil well that's a taliban's a
group so an individual can do evil
things but that doesn't mean they're
always evil forever I know it's maybe
that's an answer well but here's a
question though if the group exists
specifically to ban people together to
do something evil then is the group
itself evil I think it's it's tough
because if I put a Taliban sticker on my
chest it doesn't just not even
necessarily the Taliban like we're just
talking about I'm curious about your
view of groups and I don't think General
this makes people if I slapped like a
swast some some Insignia red it doesn't
turn me evil it doesn't also I could
take it off my chest and I'm still Ian
well I would agree it doesn't turn you
evil but don't you think that kind of
signifier displays what's going on
inside which could indicate whether you
are leaning towards good actions or evil
maybe it's correlative but not causative
well yeah I mean I I don't know so like
if someone else comes and slaps uh a
swastika on you that doesn't that
doesn't make you a Nazi the patch
doesn't cause it but I think it causes
people to know where your loyalties lie
when you wear it maybe not no it causes
them to consider where where they lie
but they definitely don't know just
because the way I look or the group I'm
affiliated with hmm all right no legs no
problem TV says Gen X are the kids of
Boomers 1965 to 1979 Millennials are 80
and on uh I'm a millennial I'm uh
near I wouldn't say late Millennial but
closer to the end of millennial and my
parents are boomers yeah same for me
same I'm X I'm the last year of X and my
parents are boomers ah yeah overlap so
it's it's it's a it's a gradient across
the board it's not like there's just one
generation then one generation but
typically LeapFrogs like the bulk is a
leapfrog like my my kids would be not
Millennial I'd be Gen X with like Alpha
gen kid kids or something yeah your kids
would be gen Alpha I'm gonna call it
Alpha gen it's called generation I'm
switching it he's changing it yeah
that's Ian's prerogative all right let's
grab some more of these super chants
real quick
let's see
car uh crafty veteran says hey Tim have
you seen Showtime's new documentary
series trailer everything's going to be
all white because seeing it cause quite
the controversy today no I don't know
what that's about do you guys want a
super racist thing that's just like
white people are you know bad and like
they're doing all sorts of bad things
and here's a bunch of people of color
talking about how systemic racism it's
like how boring who makes that and
thinks they're doing anything
interesting so tedious if you know Ian
let me ask you a question are white
people evil as a group would you would
you at least say that there are no words
let me ask you a question if um
if a group of people were demanding the
right
for the government to discriminate on
the basis of race would you oppose that
yeah what if they won and started
discriminating on the basis of race
would you be upset with it yeah what
would you be willing to do to stop them
from violating the rights of people
based on their race
usually what I do is I make TV shows and
yell and convince people to change their
minds
I suppose the the more difficult
question is Ian if you saw a guy had
taken any racial minority literally
chained them up in their backyard and
was forcing them at a whip crack to do
hard labor what would would you try and
stop that person yeah call 9-1-1
what if what if you're in the middle of
nowhere and there's no cell service
post-apocalypse in yeah I don't I don't
think I would attack the situation it's
too dangerous you'd let the I'd have I'd
know that it was there and I would
report it so let's say you're armed I
don't think I would attack the situation
it doesn't it's not safe that's not a
safe situation what if the guy's a
complete just a total wimp no guns he
has nothing he has no by the way I'm
useless yeah you could totally take this
guy no no no let's say you're armed with
a gun and you see a man who's enslaved
another man would you save the person
who's been enslaved
the slave of the slaver not no not today
not me in the 22 20. that's the craziest
thing to me like like would you guys
yeah I I like I liked I like to think
there was there if it's it's you're
there's no cell service anywhere and you
come across a guy who's enslaved another
man let's say it's a racial minority
you're armed would you attempt to free
the man who's been slaved enslaved and
use Force if necessary by the way he's
not asking for legal advice he's asking
for philosophical
I mean moral ethical questions uh what I
I mean I don't know I mean I mean it's
kind of crazy I think the answer is very
very simple Yes 100 I would yell to the
guy back the F off Get Away Now where's
the key to the chains but what if he
pulls out a weapon
if if someone enslaved another person
and like literally probably got a weapon
on him and had a weapon on him I would
act in defense of others and use the
force necessary to to stop that's that
situation is he does he even care that
he's a slave I mean
what yes I I'd imagine we're slaves to
the system
would you want someone with a gun to
come save me and do that bro thank you
they've tried no thanks I don't need to
save me right now that I think are cut
like that big government intervening in
slavery relations
let me simplify it in for you if you saw
a big fat 50 year old bald guy with a
seven-year-old little girl with a chain
around her neck and he was dragging her
and you were armed would you would you
use the force necessary to save that
little girl he's dragging her across the
ground and hurting her that's a
different story what's the difference if
I just see a slave like a guy chained up
sitting there that's different than
seeing a kid get dragged but let's say
you're it's a field you're coming across
the field you got no cell service you're
armed and you see a big fat nasty
looking slobbering guy with uh you know
10 year old girl in Chains crying and
screaming her wrists are red and he's
laughing at her and he's like I own you
I would take control of the situation
with the weapon and if he had a weapon
at fire if he saved his weapon so so
when it comes to racial minorities you
wouldn't intervene but when it comes to
Children you would well if they're in if
they're if any human I don't care what
race they are if they're being if
they're a child they're being dragged
across the ground by someone I will
intervene but like General slavery
you're fine with like if they're it's
not my position to go destroy someone's
slave environment I would love to I like
what do you want me
to
America
John Brown I know John Brown was intense
very I have him on my Twitter page but
I'm not advocating invading China to on
to free the uyghurs I I think I would
love to free the uyghurs yeah but here's
the thing I think you're I think you're
um extrapolating what your answer might
be to other more complicated situations
Tim's just asking in this specific
situation it's not necessarily how that
applies to China right but I think I
think Ian's issue is that he doesn't
want to answer these these moral
questions so instead deflect but it's
also 1003 but I want to let's go
all right we'll go to the member segment
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
come listen to our morality debate on
whether or not you would use Force to
free slaves it's an interesting question
now that you say it like that it
actually I don't know maybe you sound
like
I want to bring this conversation into
abortion and and the modern era so go to
timcast.com we're gonna have this
conversation it'll be Evergreen it'll be
good for we have a lot of we have a lot
of shows about this and religion stuff
so uh support the channel by being a
member smash the like button subscribe
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast follow us
on Instagram will you want to shout
anything out
um yeah internet accountability project
the iap.org also just follow me on
Twitter at Will Chamberlain
hi I'm Seamus Coughlin I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom Tunes we release
a new cartoon every Thursday we have one
coming out this week that I think is
pretty funny about uh federal agents and
we also released a cartoon today about
the Joe Rogan public apology and it
actually has Tim guest starring as Dr
fauci so if you guys want to check that
out go over to youtube.com freedomtunes
hit subscribe hit the notification Bell
and check out the new cartoons as I
released thank you Ian everyone's typing
one in chat that means I win oh no that
means type of one if you love me all too
late yeah I want to go special shout out
to Luke radkowski who's in the chat
right now of course and I got his shirt
on right now this is a we are change
shirt oh snap this is awesome it's got
so true all the different dystopian
worlds and in the middle you're here I
don't necessarily agree with that Loop
but I'm wearing shirt because I love you
and I love the shirt and uh you can get
these at the bestpoliticalshirts.com
follow me at Ian carlson.net and I just
rolled a 20 by the way and you won't you
won't even take a stance on the shirt
you're wearing oh my God
I love it
um I firmly agree with the shirt I have
to say that I think the world we're
living in is a weirder and worse
dystopia than any portrayed in any of
these books I'm hoping that it's about
to get brighter uh it's very dark right
now anyway you guys may follow me on
Twitter on Minds at Sour Patch Lids we
will see you all at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out bye guys